I fucking do it, okay, all right, it's just like, oh, my
mic's not, I can do it, I do my mic was good, all right,
sorry, my GoXLR reset itself, and oh my god, you guys don't
aren't even alive, oh, I forgot how to be a streamer, it's
been so long, it's been five days, I forgot how to stream,
give me a second, I'm a mess, all right, don't worry, you
guys, You guys are alive.
You're alive.
You're in five whole days.
I forgot how to stream.
It's been too long.
Okay, let me fix everything.
I need to fix everything real quick.
Okay.
All right, so we're here right now because I have a lot of
stuff to catch up on because I've been gone for five whole
days.
For those who don't know, I did put all the life updates on.
I sound like shit.
I know because I got sick.
I got sick again.
I know I fully recovered.
I'm coughing again, by the way.
I was like, yay, no more coughs.
And then my body was like, oh, bed.
It's time.
Push the button.
So I'm giving you a reset everything.
All right.
And so long story short, um, what happened was that, um, I,
I, no, I'm, no, I literally did not sleep much last I have
coffee right now I have a caramel macchiato at the moment um
basically what happened was that I felt good about myself uh
on Monday well actually no it hit me on Monday I felt good
about myself um on Sunday and Monday morning so I was just
like you know what i'm gonna touch some grass i fully
recovered from my month-long sickness in january you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go outside and touch some grass
i'm gonna go out and eat and then my body was like no i was
like yeah guys next week i'm gonna relax more we're gonna
have more chill streams uh hell month is over i was like
next week we're just gonna the last week February um we're
just gonna relax not to worry too much and like no more
pressure and then my body was like it's time it's time to
self-destruct you want to relax what about relaxing in bed
out of your own outside of your own free will and I was like
don't not that kind of rest.
I didn't mean that kind of rest.
I just, I just wanted, I wanted still to be able to do work.
I wanted to still work though.
Out of your own volition.
So, um, but it was bad.
It was bad because now I am five days behind on actual work
stuff.
I, I'm so behind.
My manager was not happy and then but then he was like i
can't do anything about it because you're sick i was like
and i'm and and then my master's like are you on your pc i
was like no i'm on my bed right now and then like you know
we would have our meetings and then he's like you're on
you're in bed right now on your phone aren't you and i'm
like yeah so no he's mad but he's like you can't do anything
about it because he can't force me to do anything because i
was literally i was so sick i just bed uh yeah dad's at the
dog sitter by the way um because like i legitimately i can't
i could barely take care of myself let alone another living
breathing being like living breathing animal i could not
take care of myself um so so he's at a dog sitter at the
moment um he's having the best day of his life oh best week
of his life um so um so yeah like uh so i was forced to like
stay in bed i it was really bad like i was just i was just i
had like i think i had a fever because i just i was i felt
really cold and everything even though i was like in a
blanket like under like the sheets and everything i was
still feeling really cold like i just didn't i was just
never on the pc i don't i think i was on the pc for the last
like four days i was on pc yesterday because i was like all
right yokey it's time to actually catch up on everything you
missed out on which was like one percent of the work i got
one percent that's why i tweeted my schedule at like four in
remember what time I tweeted the schedule.
I was like, oh shit, I gotta make the schedule.
And I made it at like three or four in the morning, even
though it was like two things.
Because I was like, if anything, I was like, if anything, I
have to be recovered by today because of the sponsor.
By the way, thank you to MSI for sponsoring me for today's
stream.
I'll give more details on the sponsor later.
But at the end of the stream, I will be, MSI has provided me
10 free game codes to give away to you dragoons for the
Resident Evil launched yesterday so huge shout out to msi
they've always been um super supportive of me so thank you
again msi for the sponsor anyway back to the story yeah so
10 lucky dragoons will have a chance to win um a free uh
resident evil requiem game code all you need to do is make
sure we can dm you on twitter uh from the official dokey
merch twitter account not from me from a staff member we'll
dm you um uh on the dokey merch twitter account so make sure
your dms are open and that we can contact you through dms on
twitter uh to claim your prize anyway other than that um
other than that okay back to the story where was i uh but
yeah no i was like super fucked up and everything because
like i'm so behind on a lot of shit right now by the way
luckily um so i was like no matter what even though i'm
still sick today i still have to stream it because it was an
obligation and they were like at first they were like can
you stream the lodge and i was like i was like i'm so sorry
i i don't think i can be alive at 9 p.m i was just like i'm
so sorry i i have 100 percent certainty that i will not be a
person at 9 p.m pst at my current state i was like i need
one more day really need one more day to like be like
coherent on stream i was i was like literally literally i
was i forgot i also i forgot to stream because i was like
rushing everything i forgot i was like oh i got set up
everything again i almost went live on twitch because that
was the last time i went live um i was like i need i need
one more day i really did i was so so bad i was like i need
one please.
One more day.
I was like, I was like, Doki, can you, are you able to do a
gorilla stream?
And then my body was like, no.
My body's like, go back to bed, Doki.
I was like, you're right.
I shall return back to bed.
Anyway, but yeah, no, I, I legitimately I was just like five
days is a long time I feel really bad to you guys because
like you know I miss you guys and I know you guys are like
what have I'm so hungry where does she go I'm gonna starve
I'm like and I'm just in bed actually dying
the turkey bird will return to bed anyway other than that
it's crazy though we so many things happen while I was gone
like I felt like everything that could happen like every
news every event just dropped while I was not streaming and
I'm like are you fucking kidding me this is why we're gonna
be yapping for a little bit before we go into Resident Evil
record because there are so many things that happen in the
last five days first off all right let me look through my
list so distracted by pre-chat yapping that like i forgot to
set up my stream i was like literally like talking to you
guys in chat like typing you guys in chat i was like oh wait
i got a stream i forgot the streaming part about the about
this about content creation not being a not just being a
lurker on on my own chat yeah i was being a lurker in my own
chat um anyway um all right first off let's see let me look
at my list before we begin first off uh oh Uh, great.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Thank you Um, hey, Doki, wanna show love and drop by the
stream?
I received a controller merch yesterday.
Yeah, I saw a lot of people receiving the controllers.
Um, and it looks amazing.
Love to you to the dragons and make sure you're all hydrate
and restful.
Thank you.
Thank you for the magenta super.
And I'm glad that, um, I'm glad that a lot of guys got your,
uh, controllers now.
Now you can match with me.
Yay.
All right.
Um, yeah, oh wait, that's me.
I should be online right now.
Yeah.
I'm like, who are, why?
Why is the streamer late, man, guys?
I was like, wait, I'm the streamer.
Wait, I'm supposed to go live.
They're all waiting for me.
Shout out to you.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Brokoo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Tokyo, it's my birthday, and I hope I could get a happy
birthday.
I've always loved your humor and your streams are always a
good time with you and the dragoons.
Much love and support from Denmark.
Thank you for the super chat, Brokoo.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
birthday dear broku happy birthday to you yeah happy
birthday happy birthday um all right what was that okay so
first thing the first day that the first thing that happened
when i was sick is that new overwatch drop guys we're
finally getting overwatch 3 it's on mobile for those who
don't know overwatch just announced overwatch rush which is
essentially essentially an Overwatch game, but for your
phones, which is apparently just Brawl Stars.
And the funniest shit, it was so funny because I was like
watching the trailer.
I never played Brawl Stars before, but people were like, oh,
it's just Brawl Stars, but what if it's like, it's Overwatch
characters?
And it's so funny because they have the original roster,
like when the game first released, it starts with the
original roster when Overwatch first released, and then
Kierico.
And they were like, of course, of course they're going to
add Kierkegaard.
They're like, and then the funniest shit is that for those
who didn't know, people were like hard complaining about it.
I'll show you guys a tweet about it.
And then, okay, so there's highlight intros.
There's a highlight intros.
She's so greedy.
Their greed knows no bounds.
But like, the thing about it was that everyone has highlight
intros, obviously.
And Kierkeau's highlight intros is like, I swear to God,
like, like five minutes long.
And then Lucio was like, three seconds.
He was like, does like backflips, teleports, peace sign,
smirks, rush, all.
And then Lucio was like, beat drop.
No.
everyone was like what and then but but wait there's more
there but wait there's more guys um so there's new skin
releases um that's uh specific to the mobile game so um new
exclusive skins that are just mobile game for for the mobile
game and also house thank you for the uh Welcome to Tomato
Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
And, um, Mercy has two new exclusive skins for Overwatch
Rush.
Um, Kiriko has two new exclusive skins for Overwatch Rush.
Lucio has zero skins.
He has zero skins.
What did he give?
And everyone was like, and everyone was like, what the fuck?
I was like, why?
What do you mean Lucio gets zero skins?
Like, he was part of the OG Like, bro has no skins It does
look hilarious Oh, yeah, also King, thank you for the super
chat Thank you, thank you Can I also get a happy birthday?
Of course you can Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to
you Happy birthday, dear King Happy birthday to you Yeah,
happy birthday So, yeah, they forgot he's been starved.
He's been starved and left out to die.
All right.
So, anyway, that is the Overwatch news.
Don't worry, there's a lot more.
There's a lot more that I want to talk about.
New Pokemon.
I'll go straight to the newer stuff that happened literally
today.
But I didn't realize we were getting, I guess it's because
this is the 30th anniversary, so that makes sense.
But new Pokemon draft.
They released the new Gens.
I think my favorite part, I made a tweet about it for those
who don't use Twitter.
But literally, okay, let me show you guys what they look
like.
Spoiler alert for those who also, they also, okay, before I
show you guys that, I will have to say, I am not a fan of
the new Pikachu's because I feel very uncomfortable.
I feel so uncomfortable with the new Pikachu designs because
like because I it's just ain't right I I don't just by the
way the new Pikachu names are mr.
windy chew and miss wavy chew because the new game is
Pokemon wind and Pokemon it was like Pokemon windy and
Pokemon wavy but the one thing that made me the most
uncomfortable about okay let's see All right, here you go.
This is what they look like.
But I swear to God, they look like...
They look like they're part of a club.
And, you know, the swinging kind of club.
What the fuck?
Why are they dead?
Because they're apparently...
Apparently, they're shiny Pikachu's.
That's why they're 10.
But I'm just...
Also, why is Miss...
Why is Miss Wavey Chew?
They look like they're...
They look like they're retired from Florida.
They look...
Yeah, they look like they just retired.
They're on a cruise.
They're on a cruise right now.
A very special kind of cruise, might I add.
um yeah yeah yeah so i don't know um yeah there's the old
couple across the bar that just really liked your vibe and
invited you over there thank you for the super chat buddy
thank you thank you anyway other than that oh yeah by the
way forgot better overwatch news um mirror's coming to
overwatch and guess who mirror i was like i was like oh of
course that's who's gonna be the way I overwatched I was
like of course Kierko gets to be near Kierko gets to be
every main character um um anyway how do I thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you they look like the tourists
from the old James Bond movie with the sub guard thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you it's so she's so
greedy all right all right let me grab oh my god okay I I
could find like every image every Photoshop image of the new
Pokemon except for the actual i have to go to the official
twitter anyway so this is what the new starter the new
starters for gen 10 apparently holy shit we're a generation
10 now um which is surprising i will say the graphics
surprisingly looks really good um like it doesn't look like
they rushed it compared to the last one the graphics
actually look incredibly impressive no it's a pomeranian um
but it's a bird a pomeranian and a gecko but like i love all
the memes already but um all right i'm gonna show you guys a
new image it's but there's it's like i'm a new picture but
one thing is different because that's what they look like
like they're the same picture isn't it i know it's the same
picture um
it looks like it they basically look like angry fly angry
bird toby fox and and and the baddest bitch you know because
she's gonna i'm sorry but you could tell she's gonna be a
the gecko's gonna be a fucking bat okay it could go both we
could go either way i swear to god the water starters a lot
of them either they're the baddest bitch we know or they're
are the gaius the gaius pokemon in the region i it's one or
the other um
so it's it could go both ways but i feel like the gecko is
gonna stand on two legs and then and then and then there's
no rules against pokemon batman don't you do not the get-go
paturasu thank you for the super chat thank you thank you so
yeah we have angry bird toby fox and a real baddie
you know they're i i'm ready to bet i'm really well ready to
bet that they're gonna furry bait I mean, look at you.
Did you see?
Okay, okay.
Look, I saved it.
But the official Pokemon Twitter for the United Kingdom, let
me show you the tweet of what the official Twitter account
from a Pokemon from the United Kingdom.
look at look at what they tweeted about the gecko if that if
that is not a hit of what we're gonna get i don't i don't
know what is i don't they gave us they gave us the fingers
nail polish emoji
so um so yeah either be out of batty or very very gay could
go either it could be both it could be answer slay girl also
I realized that he looks he does look like Lil's pet shop
but like look at those eyes I would say a word but I don't
have an Australian pass um simple minded thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you it's time for another round
of which you were snuffing with paladoki thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you hmm all right what else what
else so many new updates oh yeah oh yeah by the way um the
new pokemon game is uh a little australian here i'm gonna
give you the bat
anyway also for those who don't know the new pokemon game is
gonna be based off of water because it's literally Pokemon
wind was it Pokemon windy or Pokemon wavy and I thought it
was like we went we went a full circle because IGN was like
that's a lot of water because for those who don't know when
Pokemon um no sorry wind and wave so I was thinking of Mr.
Windy and White are they married like are these Pikachu's
married like seven point is IGN was like the history um but
a long time ago when Pokemon Sapphire and it was Sapphire
Ruby right Pokemon Sapphire and Pokemon Ruby it first came
out IGN gave the game seven out of ten because there was too
much water and then IGN was like um as a throw back they saw
the new trailer and it was literally even more water it was
more water than we've ever seen before i think it's like
because it's like you're traveling to islands this time it
was the most water we've ever seen in a pokemon's game and
then they're like oh no you know they got ptsd they're like
that is a lot of water and then pokemon was like 7.8 out of
10 it's the it's the most water they've ever seen in their
yeah so it was it this will be the most water we've ever
seen in our lives we're i thought that was i thought that
was a really nice throwback a nice throwback to simpler
times oh yeah and then i heard marathon is marathon made a
freebie sir like made free day for their game um and they're
crashing and burning right now so that's unfortunate that's
that's oh that's that's that's awkward they're like oh this
i feel bad for them because um they're like oh yeah we're
gonna have a day where marathon is gonna be free for
everyone to like entice people to try their game out and
like uh maybe pre-order their game and apparently it
backfired and now everybody a lot of people cancel their
pre-order i'm just like oh that's that's awkward so it ended
up causing people to cancel the pre-order because of the
free day so i was like oh that did not go as planned i uh i
the only gripes i had i didn't i didn't try the new i didn't
try it during the free day what's it called server slam i
didn't try because you know i was i was bed slamming like
out of there i'm out like i was i was not a person just in
bed i was just fucking sleeping um and um and then um i
heard the main complaints was that um was that the ui is
just really difficult yeah the ui is just i i remember we
did we tried the game out during one of the was a beta test
i hated the ui i was just like not a fan of the ui it's so i
don't even know where to click so like you assume they made
it better but apparently it's still hard to navigate it's
still like hard to navigate everything is like super
confusing and all that shit like that's all i've heard about
it um um but that's all i know i didn't i didn't really
check it out i didn't check it i just saw like like clips
about it and tweets about it so i feel bad because like i
feel bad for the game company and the players um because
destiny players are mad regular players are mad normies are
mad you're mad you can't win there's three players like we
waited yeah destiny died so marathon could drown like i was
just like oh oh oh oh yeah no also mr broken bond thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you if any of the
starters stand up in the new pokemon game oh you know i hope
the dog stands up just so i can see the world burn i
I hope the dog stands up.
I,
I, I, oh my God.
Oh, I can't wait.
I cannot wait for Twitter when the dog stands up.
Oh, I just, just to see the world burn.
I, you're evil.
I was like, oh my God, the dog is so cute.
I'm like, oh, I hope the dog stands up and then he turns
ugly.
I, and then he, and then he, abs I hope the dog stands up
has abs and people were like Doki it's been 15 years and
then bring back firefighting because the PTSD never leaves
you it might apparently people were like Doki it's been 15
years since the last firefighting type matchup for the
starters and I was like it might be 15 years but the trauma
never leaves they had oh my god when the fire when the
firefighting thing became a thing and like we had they
always bait us with the cutest fire type ever and then they
and then bam fire fighting
they they always they always do it they're like oh my god
torchik you're so fucking cute.
Oh, bam.
Firefighting.
He has abs now.
Yes.
It was only three.
Yes, but it was three generations in a row.
We never had a break.
It never stopped in there.
So my dream for the new gen is for the dog to walk and start
lifting weights so I can see the world burn and have
everyone relive their trauma and it started with the fucking
chicken nugget.
Okay, Doki, let's get you back to therapy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
that would be my wish that would be my paradise for me not
for the rest of the world all right what else what else um
oh yeah you got a word live action came out it looks ai i
know someone's gonna ask me oh yes by the way i will not be
playing the dlc because i realize i was uh i was reading
through chat i was starting with people and apparently i
will enjoy i would enjoy the dlc more if i had knowledge um
if i had knowledge of the rematch like not rematch of the
original trilogy because it does a throwback it helps ends
credo's story apparently and it does a throwback to like the
original trilogy and i know nothing about the original
trilogy by the way so i think it would better if i play the
remix and then i do the dlc to end it all so like it ends
the entire arc you know it ends the god of war arc where it
closes the story of god of war for me so i think that was
that would be like the best way to end it but it'll be a
while because the remaster is gonna take a while yeah yeah
so because the dlc ends create a story right so i feel like
you if you if it ends the story i should know what his story
was because i legitimately the only thing i knew about his
original trilogy story is that he fucked a lot of people um
there is sex there's sex games in there there's sex mini
games in there press press o to bang i guess and uh he
killed all the gods that's all i know oh yeah and and he
wears his dead wife and the daughter as like um as like part
of his skin that's yeah so that's like all i really know but
it's like i guess it's just like oh and he's very very angry
that's mash circle yeah mash circle to thrust so so i feel
like and i know some people that that's all you need to know
but i still feel like i should i should like try out the
rematch like the original trilogy before i end his story um
other than that wait what else was i was talking about
before oh yeah the live action So for those who didn't see
the tweet, Amazon has released the first look of Kratos and
Arteus, Arteus, sorry, Arteus in for Prime.
And I swear to God, this looks like AI.
It's like I'm looking at Arteus and I'm like, bro.
Like, what the fuck is this?
Like,
like what what the fuck is this why does he like why does he
look like that what he looks like a little bitch I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry it's a kid it's a kid but like I'm sorry
but like I guess that's why he was like boy you gotta be
tougher like you gotta be strong I'm like look at him
there's no way that boy is gonna be strong I'm sorry look at
him but I mean he needs to be able to open that jar first um
like it looks like he looks like he looks like he needs help
opening a fucking jar of pickles i'm so sorry like he is not
he ain't killing nobody like he ain't killing anyone um
apparently apparently i don't know i hope it's ai this
better be this i don't know yet um
AI, but at the moment, this looks like it came from the
official Twitter.
It looks like it came, it looks like AI, but this, this,
this, this, it's real.
Unfortunately, unfortunately, like, it came from the
official Twitter, so I,
so so unless it's april falls they scheduled it they
scheduled it late early
because i'm like bro like i don't know it does it looks it
looks so wrong it looks it does not look right like i am
surprised the boy could even even that ball i'm surprised
the boy can even pull the string that far like he looks like
he has to go to kindergarten i'm like i i'm sorry he looks
like crados took the boy out of kindergarten class and gave
him a plastic bowl because there's no way that little that
little kid can i can get hurt anything like that looks like
a toddler yeah
so yeah um anyway that's the god of war news what else oh my
god there's so many maybe i'll give you guys more updates oh
yeah smiling friends smile my oh she's graduating april my
oh she has in smiling friends um uh for those who didn't
hear a lot of people got really mad i was just like whoa
which is understandable because i i quote that shit all the
time oh yeah by the way i finally unpacked this
what is that so remember my confessional that i have where
if i press it it will go you will you will be forgiven so
they made other stuff too and i was at a bookstore i know
not to read obviously not to buy books obviously to buy like
real things um like this and it's basically a miniature tiny
trumpet and then whenever i press the trumpet it does this
also i bought a gavel it had a tiny gavel and then when i
when i hit the the wood thing on the tiny gavel this is what
it does obviously items that i need in life you know basic
necessities of course money well spent um oh yeah so um oh
shit i already forgot what i was gonna talk about um
I forgot why I brought that up.
Why did I bring up my mini trumpet?
Oh yeah, now that I showed it on stream, I can write it off.
Oh yeah, smiling friends.
This cat was going to end on April.
See, it works.
It works on stream.
Anyway, that's a tax write-off right there.
That's a business expense.
That's a business expense right there.
So a lot of people are super...
I'm sad because it's so quotable.
It is one of my favorite shows that...
Animated shows that came out recently.
It's crazy.
It came out four years ago.
It did not...
Or three years ago.
It does not feel like a three to four year old show.
Feels so recent.
But they're like...
We don't want to drag it out for too long.
So it makes sense.
But...
um it was a little sad uh because they did say they were
gonna make season i i think the funniest is that people were
like they saw they saw they didn't want to they didn't want
to recreate the Sichuan chicken shit like the Sichuan sauce
they didn't want to recreate it they didn't want another
Sichuan sauce situation because i thought swim made a video
about not the not the pin mom and heap comic but like
there's a video of a bunch of like fans going to like um a
live like a event a smiling friends event and there was a
lot of cringe things that were happening there and then
there people and then people were tweeting like they saw it
they didn't want another situan sauce incident i
die here or live long enough to become a villain yeah they
go up high that they're like it's gonna get they saw where
it's heading they saw
um so the season's ending the last two episodes are airing
on april i'm really sad because i quote a lot of shit from
that show like it was just i'm a new grounds kid so um you
know like you know like the march i'm your character like
shit like that they all comes from new ground quotes and
everything I always quote a lot of shit from new grounds
because my humor is basically based off of new grounds and
like you know from the episodes like stop fighting
um so it's unfortunate um I got really sad when the nonsense
was made anyway I guess I've been yapping for 42 minutes and
we got actually this technically is a sponsored stream so We
gotta play Resident Evil because the sun is going down and
I'm not playing this game at night All right, let me fix my
audio too real quick.
I forgot to fix my audio for this one.
I like here Where's the output?
There it is.
Uh, what the fuck?
Where the fuck is?
Oh, there's system system Okay, that's on the right one.
All right.
Is my audio guy here today?
Okay, yeah, so another thing I want to talk about, I heard
that, um, I did play the demo, quote, they go to the super
chat, they get thank you, Dragoon eats.
Um, I did play the, well, I didn't play it.
I watched Doobie play it.
Uh, when Capcom invited me to New York Comic-Con, uh, to
play several demos of a bunch of their games that were about
to come out.
And, um, And Resident Evil was the one that invited me to,
like the main one.
And we got to play Grace.
And I did not like playing Grace.
Well, I did not like watching Doobie play Grace.
But it was not great.
Basically, when you're playing as Grace, it's like a real
horror game.
But then when you play as Leon, it's like you're playing
Call of Duty, I guess.
like you're playing you're playing black ops zombies and
you're just like boom boom like oh my god is it raining ammo
like wow pew pew pew pew but then like grace yeah leon is
fps and grace is like survival mode like you're you have
nothing like you're just a regular guy like
yeah well leon you are you are the you are the monster in
the game uh yeah hunter versus hunter so i'm not really
looking forward to the grace portions because like i never
do well with horror but thankfully my pain and suffering is
monetized by msi thank you msi again for the sponsor um for
those um who were not here at the start msi is sponsoring
today's stream so at the end of the stream um they provided
us with 10 free game codes that you can activate on steam to
you dragons um so as a giveaway so there will be a giveaway
at the end of the stream um and i'll be giving away 10 free
codes to any dragon that wins the giveaway and the only uh
criteria is that you have to be able to be able to be uh
sorry you must be able to be dm'd by you must have dms open
so my staff can dm you on a doki merch twitter account um
what else what else uh so you must that uh handles the jokie
merch twitter account is asleep right now so so they will
contact you when they wake up um so please if you if you
don't have twitter dms open um they will be they will be
contacting the next person um uh they will be contacting the
next person and like they will give it to another drag room
so just letting you guys know right now um that um if you
don't have twitter dms open and they aren't able to reach
out to you that your code might will be given to another
dragoon that is a way that what is reachable on twitter dms
so just give you guys a little warning um so anyone can win
anyone can win without sorry so i haven't spoken like i
haven't spoken words in a long time like because if i try if
i talk to myself then that's then i'd be crazy um sorry when
i was sick the voice is stopped so it's been a while since
i've used my mouth uh how do you enter um just be at the end
of the stream and then it'll be like exclamation point enter
when i start the giveaway and then it's just like
exclamation point enter but not now not at the end of the
stream um also before i begin um uh the promoter doing msi
is doing a special promotion right now oh my god my room is
so humid right now my room is so hot uh it's so It's like,
and it doesn't help that I'm sick as well.
So it's been a while since I've been in my fucking green
room, by the way.
The room with no windows, with no ventilation.
Wow sick is not ideal.
It's not the greatest to be in the room with no ventilation
or windows or door.
There is a door, but like, you know, it's the only door.
Wow sick, not the best.
Yeah.
so msi is doing a special promotion right now um for their
newest monitors and if you buy selected msi monitor and post
a review on the designated platform to claim you can claim a
resident evil record on pc game code so here it is you guys
want to check it out to claim your pc game code um and if
you already purchased an msi product before and purchased an
msi selected monitor you can get an extra steam wallet of up
to a hundred us dollars so if you already have an msi
monitor you have an msi product you can claim a hundred
dollars um on steam please stop no spamming read the i am
above the law um um also for those who are wondering i'm
actually currently using um one of the msi monitors uh is
the msi mpg 271 qr qd o led x50 so that is the monitor i am
using right now and also use it for ring because i get like
500 hertz by the way it's really good especially if um
especially if you are a competitive player because um it's
actually i get 500 hertz for it uh and and um it has
improved my gameplay too so i would say is one of my
favorite monitors at the moment because i used to play with
280 hertz and now now i've seen the way i i've seen the
light um and qd olid is the best choice for resident evil 9
and um and yeah that's the one i'll be using right now
anyway uh what else before i start oh yeah my cleaner just
my cleaner finished my cleaning my apartment today and it's
they took a break for like two months because they were on
vacation and then oh my god it's crazy i didn't I forgot how
I was like, I was like, my apartment's all right.
And then they came over and cleaned it.
I was like, oh my God, my apartment was apparently not all
right.
Oh yeah.
Before I forgot to mention, there's so many things.
Like I said, so many things are going on.
But there is new merch right now that got released.
I'll talk more about this later.
Well, I'll do a, I'll be a little chatting stream too.
Because I do miss streaming with you guys.
I do miss streaming for you guys.
yapp all i just want to yapp and that's why i was late too
because i was just so busy yapping that like in pre-chat
that forgot to yapp in real life but i have a special
collaboration with senpai squad who you makes like car
related products and stuff like stuff for cars like air
fresheners um license plate frames and stuff like that so
yeah check it out it's a special collab if you want to like
um deck out your car with some sweet ass dokey bird merch uh
check it out but i'll talk more about it in detail i just
thought you guys saw the car the um the tasha is that what's
called the tasha wrapped uh car um with my face on it and i
actually went 50 50 with senpai squad for it it's not like
uh so it's not a semi-squad fully sponsored the car um it's
a collaboration with them uh because um i thought it was
really cool and they're they're known to tour their cars
around the United States.
And if you go to some of these conventions where they're
touring at, you might be able to grab a picture.
You might be able to grab a picture with the Doki car.
Yeah, I went 50-50.
I paid 50%.
It's so expensive.
I did not realize how expensive.
I just thought it'd be really cool, you know?
For a cool experience for you guys to like, you know, see a
real Doki Bird car like up close and everything.
and you know being able to take pictures of it's nice
publicity and I thought it would be a really cool experience
for the dragoons like for the fans but it is oh my god even
when I went 50-50 with them and oh my god I was like what
that's that's my 50% yeah car that'll never drive yeah I was
just like oh my god that's my 50% I thought I was like oh
that's the full price I ain't so bad and like no that's your
half and it's like what that's mine so so i hope you guys
are able to encounter in real life i thought it was i
thought it was such a cool thing it was like um i thought it
was just a really cool thing to be able to have a half for
you guys to experience you know be able to take picture with
one or just see it up close in real life one day um anyway
let's actually play resident evil let's boot up this game um
i will not be using the silly costume I will not I
unfortunately I will not be using the silly costumes from
the DLC we're gonna play it as it's attended for once to be
fair the costumes aren't as silly though if the costumes
were very silly I just don't think the costumes are as silly
as it should be that's why I was just like if it was silly
like like the Metal Gear Solid Silly, then that's fine.
Or like the Silent Hill Silly.
Wait, was that supposed to be TV?
Oh my god, wait.
No, wait, back.
Wait, I don't, I hope it was supposed to be TV.
Wait, was this TV originally?
I don't know if I pressed it wrong.
Yeah, it's not silly enough.
If Leon was shirtless, then maybe.
was it was it on tv i don't remember i go headphones all
right subtitle on oh make it headphones well i hope it
doesn't affect like um preempt lead oh turn sound effects
okay we'll do that later uh when we're there okay damn
that's just the pattern oh yeah i was gonna say until the
pattern is no longer visible oh it should be brighter then
pattern all right adjust the pattern until the pattern is no
longer okay okay but what if i make it just a little bit
noticeable just what if i go full bright just a little
brighter do one yeah just it's just one guys it's just a
little brighter All right, confirm.
Reparacy ability is recommended to use first person when
playing as grace to enhance the order and use third person
when playing as Leon.
I was actually going to do the opposite of that.
So, it's change perspective, first person, or third person.
Or it is don't change perspective, first person, or third
person.
look I I didn't know which one is which versus change change
perspective is custom
like change perspective okay grace this and no okay wait
okay please enter your age does it matter does it matter
does it matter
does it doesn't matter though i need to know like i need to
know
nice don't lie oh it just wants my personal info okay that's
fine is this stage will not affect them but once your age
has been confirmed it cannot be why does it what my age what
the fuck just get grab it just buy it off of google like
just like just buy off of google like every fucking company
good choice all right free analytics interesting why when it
could be free now
nice all right it's compiling shaders okay so what i'm going
to be doing is grace will be third person and then leon will
be uh oh yeah wait no grace will be a third person and leon
will also be third person because no one can like i cannot
live up to leon and also i get more view of his male-deaf
team worked incredibly hard on Leon.
So I am here to appreciate their efforts and the polygons.
I mean, we are here to see Leon, not be Leon.
We can never match to his perfection.
We cannot never live up to how perfect he is as a human
being.
I'm not good enough.
So I have to, I have to play third person as Leon, as Capcom
intended, exactly.
Prioritize performance.
Prioritize quality.
Fuck that.
No.
Wait, actually.
Yeah, quality.
I gotta see all the pores.
Alright.
Alright, I gotta reconfigure this anyway.
Uh.
Performance stable FPS.
Is it not optimized?
How optimized is this?
Oh my god, I'm gonna use keyboard and mouse.
yeah i see all the pores all right so third person god
that's so scary i fucking i cannot do that i cannot i cannot
do camera wobble bro why am i not suffering enough yeah if
i'm not dude all right there we go i knew it guys you don't
understand yeah i could be i could be leon but no one can be
leon he's too perfect
no one can live up to his expectations and standards oh yeah
i heard this game was really short too all right borderless
window auto uh image pc specs uh it's not that motion blur
off god yes i will see each individual strat holy okay maybe
it yeah it's fine
oh and not for me you're right you're right if i if i start
lagging let me know i open seam so just discard any until we
get to gameplay okay all right mesh lens distortion
upscaling nvidia lens flare shadow quality all right oh i am
lagging a little bit all right i guess it's time we'll do
high normal hot normal all right audio oh god i'm not
looking forward to this i heard racist parts are very scary
i'm not i'm not i'm not okay i need to know who's talking or
i'll be so confused I need a no.
Alright, everything.
Alright, sound effects down by 2?
Alright.
Okay, I should be good now.
Oh!
Just turn off your skin suit when the game starts so we can
see Leon.
Wait, did I turn off captions?
No, I didn't.
It's on.
What's on?
closed caption oh i should get yeah i want background
chatter i know when you know when the zombies are closed you
can't jump scare me if i see the closed captions no i cannot
handle or it's so bad like graces like i played the oh sorry
i watched dubby play the part where um where you're in the
hospital with great like with grace and like the monster
does not show up until like later but even what's the word
the environment the atmosphere and the oh there's a word for
it the like it's the atmosphere but like it was so well done
out the ambience the ambience was so fucking well done that
i legitimately like i can't even put i didn't even play with
sound by the way i sorry i didn't i didn't even watch dubie
with sound because like dubie like you won't put on the
headphones and i was like no i shall watch in silence i It's
too much, like, this, oh my god, even the sound alone was
too much.
I was like, I shall watch in silence.
Not sure how long I'll stick around for it, but I'll try to
see how far I get in this game before I stream the night.
Grace says, I know, I'm really very dokey-coded.
You know what I mean, Terminator.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, modern.
This game may have changed to casual on the game over
screen.
And ink, okay, the, yeah, no, not the class.
I will be saving a lot.
Thank you very much.
I recommend it for it.
I I will be saving a lot.
I'll be using, if they give me like a limited amount of
ribbons, we would be done by chapter one.
Like we would run out by chapter one.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
That did not have to be that loud.
Please first person for grace.
It's a better, for who?
For you.
not for me
yes yes for us I mean we can up the we can up get for a
raccoon city oh yeah for those who don't follow me on
Twitter Capcom sent me like a PR package for this game it
literally came with an actual like metal like aluminum brick
those like aluminum briefcases that you see in Resident
Evil.
It's so cool.
It came with like a little...
It came with a lighter, a key, a storybook.
And...
Oh yeah, and then at the bottom, there is like the special
collab they had with Porsche that's hidden underneath the
briefcase.
Oh yeah, and a flashlight with a black light on it.
We can turn it up for the cutscene.
I'll turn it up for the cutscene.
If I can...
if I can tab it.
I'll put it up for the cutscene, and then we can turn it low
later.
We found another body.
One that exhibits the same pathology as the others we've
been investigating.
Is that better?
Now, I need a good technical analyst on this.
Okay.
I need your eyes on the crime scene.
The Rembrandt Hotel.
At least it's not the hospital.
Okay, I turned it up a little bit more.
Oh.
that's where your mother was murdered and I know it'll be
get ready to turn it low when we need it
get your ears ready face the past confront that kid head
up grace I won't force you to go but do you think you can do
this for me
investigate that crime scene and report back to me with your
findings that's
all for now it's all right it's not the hospital i know the
hospital the hospital is where we're not at the hospital is
where i don't fuck with it's okay surely i can play leon
next right it's
just a hotel
Leo's gonna show up in this Porsche, guys.
It's okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
He's so rude.
Oh.
Renwood.
Ah, the birthday, grandma.
Almost said, happy birthday, grandma.
Merry Christmas.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I heard my birthday wish yesterday when I said, bring back
Resident Evil 4, Leon.
Thank you, female death fleet team.
Plus, early thank you, Doki, for showing Leon in his full
glory.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Leon.
Happy birthday.
Oh, it looks so pretty.
This game looks really pretty.
All right.
Sound guy.
Get ready.
That's right.
Oh, you look like you're gonna...
You look like you're busy.
That's right.
This is my sidewalk.
Where am I supposed to go?
This is really pretty.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah, apparently this is like the second highest Resident
Evil game so far.
Ooh.
Okay, this does not look like...
It doesn't look like a horror game yet.
Look, everyone's holding umbrellas.
It's symbolic.
it umbrella court and everyone's holding umbrellas i see
what you did there capcom
so the meaning is so deep
think about it very subtle
oh wait there was interactable i was just walking on the
sidewalk that's a restricted area you can't go in there it's
all connected oh i can bring up the game a little okay
bro oh my god oh i guess from the trauma of whatever the
hospital is linked to
oh your fbi i am investigating all these strange deaths huh
it's the fifth one now right how is this girl oh this
because the hotel is connected to like connected to
something in her past that's why she's like extra like
Anxious about it.
Hey, are you with me?
Oh, um, um, there might be answers.
I raised it up a little bit.
Do I need to raise it up even more?
Yeah, sure, right.
Yeah.
Her mom died here, yeah.
Up more?
Okay.
Whole buildings condemned.
Where it is they're finally gonna bring the whole place
down.
Be careful out there.
I heard the residents are evil.
Ha ha ha ha.
But, um...
Alright.
I should write for this game.
Alright, I raised it up a little.
No way.
She said the lie.
I should be a writer.
Kojima countdown.
why am i even here why did like they send me they could send
any i don't like this already i don't like this already i
don't like this it's okay there's no hospital as long as
there's no hospital oh that's okay it's okay as long as they
don't know it's already starting it's already starting oh no
this is not good it's okay there's no hospital.
As long as there's no hospital, everything will be okay.
Oh my god, there's so many people's birthdays today.
Uh, Roosevelt, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, I'm just, I need to scroll up.
Today's my birthday, and I was wanting to get a quick
birthday shout out to your streams.
I've been a big help for my mental, and I hope you and all
the dragons have a good night.
I love Leon.
Uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear Roosevelt
happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday all right all
right here we go who to the hotel who the freaky ass hotel
why would don't they normally send two people why one why
one who is my backup where's my emergency contact oh no oh
no oh my oh where's my gun where's my fbi assigned gun wait
oh oh no oh no oh no where is my gun what will happen to me
okay don't don't say that someone's like look up don't don't
say that don't i will never look behind me i will never look
up i'll
oh my god why is the opening animation so slow like oh my
god what is gonna happen like a fucking surprise surprise
it's a it's a fucking giraffe in the in the drawer
like oh my god surprise it's two tickets to disneyland
oh oh just open the door grace just open the door just open
the door also is my skin suit lag or is it is it okay if it
is i can turn down the graphics why two tickets for me for
me and leon that's why for who else is gonna get it oh i'll
piece a little more okay
oh god i tab oh my god okay I you can check it's a little
laggy but it's okay you can check your quiet items for I am
examining for more details all right I can fix that oh my
god okay lounge and bars it doesn't say hotel doesn't say
hotel or it doesn't say hospital port that details the
unexplained death I want to read it hello not not oh here oh
shit okay never mind all right on September 28 20 20 26 at
11 20 p.m the body of a man was found at a bandit hotel the
bio is discovered in a hotel restroom based on a level decay
it's suspected to have been there for several days prior to
this that mild cases of similarly mysterious death have been
reported locations across the united states oh god i don't
like that i don't like that Oh, I don't like that.
Night Valley.
We're survivors of the Raccoon City incident.
The victim's body all had black bruising.
Oh, it's like...
It's like the nuclear radiation.
It never fully leaves you.
I really don't like that.
Oh, too bad.
Strapping.
There's no turning back.
Oh, I really don't like that.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Are you serious?
I can't adjust this in the game.
Okay, I can't adjust this.
Okay, let's get a seat.
Let's see.
What do you mean I can't adjust this right now?
All right, it's okay.
I can adjust this, though.
What do we need?
We don't need that.
Who needs lens?
Okay, honestly, though, who needs lens flare, though?
Um, we don't...
Uh...
Hmm.
Oh, many, of course!
Hey, Doki, can you wish my friend the biggest birthday boy,
Eifin a happy birthday?
Oh, it's Eifin's birthday!
He's been a really good day.
Of course!
Happy birthday, Eifin!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Eifin!
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Alright.
guys how what can i change to have better to make sure i oh
don't worry motion blur is the first thing i turn off do not
worry what other thing can i adjust here guys to fix the
quality to fix the
lag upscaling all right what do i do it on
i'm not stalling by the way i'm just trying to increase the
quality of the stream guys i'm just just increasing the
quality oh my gosh oh oh my god ultra performance imagine
guys it's not oh my wait it looks so nice though like this
is okay well we'll do performance
maybe maybe the stuff will be less scary no no no grace look
there's no way there's scary things gonna happen to me
because i don't have a gun no gun means they won't do
anything to me right right right guys that's usually how it
goes wait that's me wait what let's talk room 204 yeah let
me not tell them let me not phone in my
I don't like
that.
I'm ready to leave the room.
Oh, there's my gun.
What do I do?
Leon, that's you, right?
There's Leon, right?
Okay, head to room 204.
Okay.
Do I not have a phone?
Ah!
all right let me use this cube all right all right let's
let's not go there let me just turn around okay
okay now i have gun now i don't feel as confident anymore
it's like don't worry nothing's gonna bad's gonna happen i
don't have a gun how would i self-defense myself if i have
no gun and then they gave me a gun and i was like oh
oh it's instant ramen oh i think it's maggots never i was
like who's making ramen in the toilet bowl oh that's gross
okay that's pretty gross i was gonna say who's making your
oh god i was ready i was ready That's fucking ready.
I am using humor to cope right now.
Are you okay?
If I laugh, it will masturbate.
We know.
All right.
I am fine.
Also, wherever we get to a checkpoint or a save, I'm
changing the graphic settings right now.
I'm corner checking to make sure I'm corner checking right
now.
Nobody in the corner, right?
Nobody in the corner.
Nobody camping me, right?
Oh?
Oh, I hate this so much.
I... Oh, I do not like this.
But it's okay.
There's no hospital.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
There's some cockroaches crunching around.
Oh, no!
Okay.
I'm fine.
I'm so healthy.
All right.
What's in this locker?
Yay.
I bet like if Leon opened that same locker, he'll get like
10 shotgun bullets and 100 rifle ammo.
Pretty privilege is real.
To all employees, following the recent incident, management
has been working hard to restore public trust unfortunately
due to the extent of the damage is unclear if it is possible
to reopen cool consequently it is with great regret that we
must announce the official closure closure of the hotel um
we apologize greatly uh for the impact this may have on you
and your families and wish to extend our heartfelt gratitude
for the support and hard work you have brought to the
long-standing business okay cool oh there's the map yay the
map yay all right 204 is here it's got why is there a third
floor i don't know he just told me to go to a second floor
so why the fuck do i see a third floor why does that exist
why does the option to see a third floor exist i don't like
that
Good news.
That does not seem very good news at all.
Don't worry, Doki.
It's just lore.
It's just trying to tell you it's a hotel.
It has more than two floors.
Hey, someone's been sleeping here.
That pillow is not as dirty as the other stuff that's going
around.
Oh, I don't like this at all.
I really don't like this.
okay there's the second floor time anything else here just
the lobby here anybody around this corner nope okay here
it's just just aesthetics all right here we go there we go
that looks like black mold i think black mold is the least
of my worries checking my corner i'm done with i'm done with
this wild ride you can take me to leon now thank god i'm not
okay wait how would this look like when first person
actually uh
what would this look like yeah no get me out of here get me
get me out of here i'm fine that that no no it's all right
what the fuck the door is closed what how do i go to the
second floor yeah no that's that's good enough for me oh
wait the second is on the third floor what is this for 1.5
what's in here oh it's a key all
right okay i know i'm still lagging but we will fix that
soon very soon the moment oh my god that looks like
medication that i should be allowed to chug down i'm sorry i
forgot it's not a green herb how the am i supposed to cut
that oh wait wait
what the oh
i i did not see the pliers sorry i'm like when you're so
scared you don't sheet see the thing that's in front of you
you know you know like when you're so scared stupid fucking
deer
all right all right what does my phone just not work i swear
to god like do they have like reception blockers in this
hotel why do i not call find open the window and be like Oh
my god, Grace, no wonder you're, no wonder you're a main
character in a scary, in a scary game.
2-0-2.
Radio static.
I'm wrong game.
This is not Silent Hill.
Why is there radio static?
I do not like that.
Excuse me.
I am in a different franchise.
Oh.
Oh my god, he's in the corner, isn't he?
He's in the corner.
Not in the corner.
Oh my god, I'm going to go to the radio and he's going to
appear right behind me, isn't he?
Come on.
You know, you're right behind me.
come on I know I'm
safe oh I'm safe okay okay it's okay it's okay I'm okay I'm
safe there's nothing to worry about it's okay oh it's a lot
of pictures of me though i don't like that and my mom
everything is fine see everything is fine it fades to black
that means she's okay
see look at that oh my god please yes oh wait i thought that
was leon but it's just I was like eight I was like Leon it's
just it was just grace eight years ago
I was like oh my god Leon where did you grow boobs what did
that happen I'm almost done just a sec what am I gonna do
with you you always do now you Leon, save me.
I was like, damn Leon, your pecs got huge.
Yes.
Oh.
That's creepy.
Who was it?
they asked for miss Ashcroft and then they hung up on me
rude
who's they grace we need to go where where's the evil mom
what's going on hurry we who's coming yeah who's coming we
need to keep our voices down this is ridiculous come on okay
I tell me what's going on now is not the time there's like
grace where is a home invasion and you want to know and you
want a yapp right now grace you have zero survival instincts
I'm sorry girl like like mom tell me what's going on is
someone's home invading us stay close the fact that I have
not saved at all I am concerned oh wait I have to run wait
but what if there's loot Mom, what if there's Luke?
Grace, hurry.
Okay.
Keep moving.
Mom, I'm missing some...
Oh, it's just a nice old man.
Oh, I'm so sorry about the power outage.
What happened?
Oh, it's probably the electrical panel.
Yeah, I've held on to it as like memories.
take much to trip it it's really no excuse and i apologize
for the inconvenience oh no it's fine yeah don't worry i
should have it fixed soon i just need to find my oh oh oh oh
he's okay right he's he's okay right it's like a little
murder history party, right?
It's just ketchup bags, guys.
Stay close to me.
Oh my god, not the guy I just met.
How are you gonna tell me what's going on?
Just a little bit eefy.
Mom, what are you doing?
Something important.
Yeah, also, like, you could just, I guess he could have just
stabbed him.
But then I guess he was worried that the old, the old man...
Oh, I have to grab that later.
The old man was gonna fight back if he doesn't suffocate him
first.
I'll explain later.
We need to find another way out.
Oh, shit.
Surely there's a green herb somewhere.
Oh, yeah.
Sound guy said sound effect by one more, which I totally
agree with.
Because that means...
That means the jump scares would be less loud.
We're calling the police.
No, don't call the police.
Boo!
Yes, I want to report a murder.
No murders.
The Redwood Hotel.
Yes!
Hurry!
Oh, now I know how to use my cell phone.
Now I know.
Can't call him now, though.
Apparently phones don't work now in eight years.
Grace.
Oh, I am having a panic attack.
I am not doing so well.
In.
yes that's what i'm saying she's fucking she's the worst
person to be in the zombie apocalypse that's what i'm saying
she doesn't call for backup and she has asthma please know
that you are my hope never forget that what are you talking
about just i love you mean mom mom you only see that when
something bad is gonna happen surely nothing bad's gonna
happen also i have to do a little bit more sound guy would
have put my macbook
okay i don't care about my macbook no more i'm sorry i i
mom I'm sorry I'm sorry about my MacBook mom wake up mom
this murder mystery party is not as fun as you said it was
gonna be mom please
oh well now we know why she has why the fuck did they send
me to the hotel that's how that is a lot to unpack i should
not have been sent back here like or at least i should have
had a chaperone well that's gonna make it harder to explain
all later because thank you for the super chat thank you
that had some heavy ptsd the fact that No chaperone for
this.
The FBI was pranking me.
It's just a prank, bro.
Yeah, that was some really good voice acting.
Oh, shit.
We went back to Blackberries.
We went backwards in phone technology.
Oh, wait.
No, it's a burner phone.
Oh.
I need to get out of here.
Yeah, I should not have answered that.
Finally.
That has to be like a GPS locator.
I'll explain later.
Oh, God.
I've got to go back to the lobby.
Oh, my God.
No.
I have to retrace my steps.
I know I didn't listen to the radio, but I was scared.
okay really there's nothing in here i'll just the slowest
surely there's nothing in here all right i was gonna say
there's no way i have to go back to the lobby first before
they give me another jump scare okay all right here i go why
can i not save yet look when oh my god of course i'm Of
course it's rain.
Oh wait, it was raining before.
When I'm on high alert, I'm not here to wait and listen.
I'm just here to leave.
This is a Leon waiting room right now.
I have to be strong enough in grace to deserve Leon.
Trials and tribulations for Leon.
Oh my god.
persons that's a that's a person's shadow wait sound guys a
little more or is this good do it for him be strong for him
I don't even remember where the painting was
guys I know we just watched the cutscene but like I'm not
okay I I'm not I
No, I'm, no, no, no, I have non-bullets.
Non-bullets is not.
If I'm going to shoot my gun, it's going in someone's body.
I'm making every shot count.
Oh, God.
Listen, oh, now you guys want me to listen to him.
Now.
Oh, fuck, guys.
Where was the painting?
It was here.
I know I could have read.
But I'm not okay.
Okay, I thought that was a lot bigger than what was in my
flashback.
I swear to God, it was not that big in the fucking
all right it's a journal okay work has settled down and
we're heading to a new town the day after tomorrow i'm
thankful my freelance work allows me to work anywhere but
i'm worried about grace it's difficult for her to make
friends when we're constantly on the move maybe we can spend
a little more time in the next town finish some research and
stopped in the cafe when i noticed watching me maybe i'm
just being paranoid oh my god 2018 i saw that hood and man
again he's definitely following me we can only we only just
got here but i think we should move on i can't let anything
happen to grace all right the moment i close this book the
moment i close this book the hood and man's gonna be like
ooga booga booga all right the moment i oh wait there's one
more oh all right the moment i close this i'm ready i'm i'm
ready for it oh my god it's a floppy disk oh my god don't
let us custom seize this don't let them see this they might
think it's foreign or drugs like
oh Oh, wait, he's okay.
What's wrong?
It looks...
What?
Are you okay?
Oh, my God, he's training.
What do I do?
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Okay, he's...
Don't...
Don't call Grace.
Why can't you do anything?
Grace, you had one job.
I had nine...
What?
What are you doing?
You're free!
I'm fracking!
Ah!
I got scared.
Oh.
Okay.
It's fine.
I let go.
Because I was.
I was like, what even?
I don't know.
I was not okay.
I'm not okay.
Guys, this is why.
This is why I told you.
I told you I will not survive.
I will not survive a zombie apocalypse I have zero survival
skills You're like evaded I'm like you mean like move
towards his gun?
Yeah, I'm what?
What?
Bobby hooves!
What do you mean?
even zombie rules!
The trouble's the end!
Okay.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Oh, my God.
I have to hold.
I just...
Don't worry.
Maybe I'm immune.
Grace is technically the main character.
Dang, you're so dead.
Don't worry.
Maybe I have to mold in me.
Did I skip the...
I don't know.
I don't know if I skipped.
How did I skip the cutscene?
I just held F.
I...
I don't even know how I skipped it.
I just held F.
Six survivors of Raccoon City all dead from the same thing.
Yeah, that's not good.
No.
No, it's not.
hey but i get to play leon now but i have something for you
the team has settled on a person of interest someone with
ties to umbrella but guys it's leon tab no don't make me
okay all right how bad is it i skipped everything i was like
it's okay guys it's leon tab i just got a report of a
missing police officer it might be unrelated but he
disappeared near where the fifth body was found you there
leon yeah i'm here you okay
it said hold to unlock the door i didn't realize i kept
holding i oh hey there's my push guys thank you forish
he looks so tight bro it's like resident evil like 20 now
and he's still he's still has to keep me he's like why
there's still zombies
okay wait i can go back i just want i can skip the leon
cutscene again almost there just about sucker traffic you've
got to be shooting me um simple-minded he's not old he's
experienced um 80 80 women developers worked very hard to
give us the leon the people wanted every wrinkle was
purposely placed what's going on oh it is going on wait
that's grace she okay why is she here i would maybe the cut
scene would have been very important just taking her
in public okay wait That breaks, that breaks breast and evil
law.
In public?
Don't have to, Victor.
Don't do anything stupid.
All right.
Okay, we...
We load game?
Oh, here.
This should be it, right?
It should be auto-save, too.
Yeah, 1853.
Escape the police officer.
All right, here we go.
He's making the residents evil!
Okay, all right, we can do this again.
Rewind time.
Look, I did this, okay?
And then, oh, I held it.
It's like, it's a whole F, and I thought it meant to open
the door.
That's what I did.
Someone stopped him.
Look, I was panicking.
it was a fight or flight response it was a flight or flight
response
i saw f okay i saw it the f key still showed up so i kept
holding it
the flight and flight
is is anyone there
Hello?
Oh, and this is where the guy picks her up.
Hey, Doki.
It's my cat's birthday today.
Can Nova get a happy birthday from her meowshi?
Of course!
Uh, Spark Tank.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Nova.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Meow.
Oh, yeah, this was a pretty big cutscene.
They're like, wait, you can do it.
Wait, Doki, stop.
It's okay, it's not the hospital.
I do remember this guy from...
It hasn't been easy.
From the demo.
But after much effort, here we finally are.
who planted that body i'm the one that brought you here i
know now that you're the one that i've been searching for
the special one the chosen one miss ashcroft who closed the
door oh my god is she psychic
oh that's how he got me
We have so much to do.
If that is my dad, we definitely did not get the looks from
him.
Bro.
My mom settled.
No wonder.
No, he didn't.
All right.
Leon time.
Yay.
Guys, you might be evil.
Okay, now.
now we can wait is this leon now oh my god he's so cool he's
so cool all right there you go i skipped one cutscene to be
led to another cutscene oh my god there we go okay we gotta
watch this part
it's him i could say it again
you almost there just about
Guys, he's gonna do it, guys.
Guys, I was gonna say, he's breaking me.
He's breaking Raccoon City laws.
You don't infect outside of Raccoon City.
Unless you're in Africa, apparently.
What's going on?
Is she okay?
Well, she's fine.
I'm just taking her home.
He's making a residence.
There you go.
I know.
He's doing this outside of Resident Evil.
This is against the law.
Leon, what's your sit rep?
I'm going off to Victor.
See it again, Yes.
Say it again.
Alright.
Is it background music?
Okay.
Me?
Never.
Wow, I gotta go after Victor.
Alright, how many bullets do I have?
Alright, there she is.
Okay.
What are you doing?
What the fuck?
Help me.
I must kiss you.
Are you really serious?
Holy shit, is he okay?
He's not gonna turn, is he?
Oh, he's gonna turn.
Look at him.
His eyes.
I got- Oh, wait, no, he's not.
His eyes were pale.
I can fix it.
Alright.
Oh, the car- Oh, my god.
Bro, come in!
He's like, bye.
It's alright.
Really?
there we go all right now all right nice heat blood loss I
was like three bullets watch this which one are you zombie
oh not zombie I gotta make sure what if that guy was just
drunk see you guys I can't hurt civilians.
There we go.
Oh shit, wait, stop the kid!
Oh fuck, okay, civilian.
It's fine.
Oh yeah, I did not save her.
For sure.
Alright, bam!
Oh my god, I still got it.
I still got it.
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait Boom!
So got it!
Oh, I should save her.
Whoa, too late.
Five.
Nice.
Alright.
Boom!
So got it.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, wait.
Where the fuck?
Boom!
That's right.
Oh my god, you're so cool.
You're so fucking cool.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, is that ammo for me?
For me?
Oh my god, Leon.
66 bullets?
Leon the Chad with his 66 bullets versus Grace the Virgin
with nine.
Well, not even nine, but one.
One.
Oh my god, wait, I was trying to... I was trying to melee
him.
Whoops.
Whip Requiem.
What's Requiem?
There we go.
Boom!
Why do I need to equip?
Oh my god, it's fine.
My HP is so healthy.
Sharpen.
What's Sharpen?
Oh shit, what the fuck is this game?
Give me a sec, I got Sharpened my axe.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec Monster Hunter time.
What did I quit?
Sharpened mid battle.
Give me a sec, I got a Monster Hunter.
What?
Oh my god, I gotta travel the longest distance for this
kick.
But it was so worth it.
All right, powerful attacks based...
There's combos?
Where is he?
Combo!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, not good, not good, not good.
I was trying to do a combo.
Not good, not good.
The combo was not worth it, guys.
The combo was not worth it.
Okay.
Why did I quit?
Is that Requiem?
Is sharpening Requiem?
Oh my god, car fight!
Car fight!
Get out of here!
This is my car.
Oh, it's this one.
Is that Requiem?
Is this one?
No, I lost them.
No, I had to look cool.
Sorry, it's too busy farming, aura.
Victor purchased a building after Umbrella went under.
The Rhodes Hill Chronic Care Center.
I'll send you the address.
He's like, he's like, I could chase after the main bad guy,
or I can look cool.
I could look cool as fuck.
right now.
Oh my God.
How could they do this?
Oh, oh, this is the demo area.
Oh, no.
This is this.
Oh.
This is the.
I, this was the demo.
I'm at the hospital.
I'm at the fucking hospital.
No.
At the hospital.
No!
Oh my god, this area fucking sucks.
I, I, the monster doesn't come in until like late game.
Everything else is just like rage bait.
Oh no.
No, take me back.
They gave me dopamine just to give me depression again.
And they took it all away.
They gave me a freebie.
They gave me the first hit.
Yeah, the voice acting for Grace is really good.
But not as good as Leon.
He's so cool.
pro leon with his fucking 70 bullets but doesn't matter
because he has a fucking axe now
all right before we do this i should have to change the
graphics because i am lagging a little like my skin suit is
lagging a little guys let me wait let me check okay yeah
escape all you that's all your game that's all your gameplay
grace every single one is just escape
okay you might have you were reading but leon got hit with
one of those darts making the residents evil you might oh
gordon thank you the super chat thing oh you mean not the
other times i got not the times i got bit 20 times i mean oh
that's crazy i thought it was when i got bit 20 times that i
finally got hit all right let's do 120 but i turn off ray
tracing okay normal but it looks so good though look at it
it's so cool it looks so good though i need to see the
reflections all right let's see what else Nah, that could be
fine.
Um, wait, why did it go from customs to not customs?
Because I was fucking around.
Wait, what was this at?
Other than...
Um...
What should upskill and quality be at?
Because I fucked up.
Performance.
Just.
Alright, time is performance low.
Let me check everything else.
That should be fine now.
Turn off lens there.
Alright.
Alright, everything should be good now.
I think.
I should not lag as much anymore.
Alright, man.
Continue.
Alright.
Okay, forward.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
May do be give you...
I think I need more than that.
Alright.
Quality is still good, right?
Yes, I think I need more than that.
I need a lot of faith in me.
That's the...
No fucking shit.
That's your blood.
That is your blood.
Okay.
Begin blood extraction.
Check pause.
No abnormalities.
Wait, oh.
Oh, I am immune.
The one time I was, I told you guys, eventually I'll be
immune.
Oh my God, I am immune.
Because like, he shot a, he shot, um, I got bit.
I got bit.
But it's okay.
I live.
I can live those.
Okay, I have to have this light on.
Oh my God, I fucking knew it.
I knew I was, okay, turn that back on.
I knew I was special.
I, the one time.
finally no mold needed yeah that's some good ass reflection
wait yep that's me
i can tink those you see the one thing i know is that no
monster shows up until like later but i still don't like
this i still don't fuck with that
That's fine.
That horse scared the shit out of me before.
Can't see shit.
Uh.
Oh, it's broken.
I can't see anything.
That's okay.
I hate this.
I really do.
It's fine.
She doesn't show up until late.
No, when the horse, even without sound, like, that's so
freaking...
the hell out of me like the horse freaked me out I actually
like screamed or like yelled yelled very madly is that a
kid's voice what the fuck was that all right there's the key
oh I hate this I do not remember when the game actually
starts though that's I'm not lagging anymore right the only
issue is that i remember the monster doesn't come in yet but
i forgot when she does come but also is the graphics okay
too that's i remember i remember she comes in but i don't i
don't remember when i oh that's the key i have this key they
send me they they gave me this there wasn't evil people the
capcom people not the yeah not oh my god there's a save
okay okay that's a safe zone that means this is the safe
zone area okay empty bottle oh okay that's okay oh fuck okay
now i remember i now i remember now i oh no i have this i
have this too they sent me this too they sent me the key and
the lighter so i have i have this as well as that's really
no no oh i forgot is there fuel is there is there fuel in
this lighter please does this fuel have this lighter use
fuel no surely surely oh yeah yeah they capcom sent me a pr
package and oh my god and like it included the key and they
made 190 of these 109 people received it and also the
lighter guys does the lighter have fuel before i use it does
it does the lighter have fuel i got oh my god you fucking oh
my god
oh my god there's the fuse oh my god i forgot about the fuse
um not okay i need a tool okay it's an infinite lady okay
okay i need a tool to fix this i don't know what i don't
know because i don't remember i'm too scared okay i can't be
scared if i have a lady
oh i don't remember when you show up i don't remember i
don't remember when you show up know I'm safe for like the
first the beginning I know you're here I know you're here
just not here but you're here oh this and this oh it all
came from this room I have this book too I have this book
okay I'm trying to turn the page okay have you seen the chat
oh yeah this they They gave us, they sent us this book in
real, like the actual hard copy of this.
She looks like Lorena, like the ghost, or the monster.
Okay, have you seen the shadow ghost?
Yes, she's been watching you.
Stay in the light.
Okay, yeah, I remember that.
Apparently, uh, lighters don't count.
That's her name, right?
The...
Lelorina?
Is that the name of the ghost?
The, like, that woman that drowned kids?
Oh, my God, okay.
I knew, like, she's not in that closet because she's big as
hell.
So, I was like, I know she's not in that closet.
It's, it's Urania.
Oh, Lelorina.
All right.
Yeah, Lelorina.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
the screwdriver is now in the toolbox oh my god okay that's
where yeah i remember she you'll understand it literally
looks like her like yorona yorona sorry not yorona yorona it
looks like her that's what the monster looks like oh my god
i'm thinking oh my god i have goosebumps right now fuck i oh
she's coming oh she's coming Oh, yeah, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, okay, not the nurse station, oh, my
God, okay, I'll remember, oh, she's here, oh, this is where
demo starts the moment I go outside this door everything
happens everything happens the moment I leave this door like
it or maybe i'll never leave i'll give you the mexican
pastless one time have fun okay i'm stalling i i'm gonna use
the bathroom i'm stalling all right i'm gonna look at this
cool-ass dinosaur give me a sec i i use bathroom goodbye and
she never came back imagine if i like it's just two hours of
you just looking at the dinosaur and be like all right guys
i guess it's getting too late guys i got caught jay allen
next year thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
uh mr broken bond thank you for the super chat thank you
little baby coward donkey neppers minler space cyber jay
solid bite wb allen may uh many four thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you all right okay here we go here we
go la yorona i'm here time to eat the kids i'm here what
la yorona
Oh, it's right here, isn't she?
Hello?
Oh.
Yummy, yummy.
Here's the nurse's room.
I know there's a dead guy somewhere here that's going to
give you a mini jump scare.
I remember you.
Mr. Dead Guy?
What the fuck?
This shelf used to be able to be...
I used to be able to open one of these shells.
What happened?
I...
No!
It coded it out of the game.
Oh!
Doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter that I remember.
She still fell for it again.
She still...
Oh, there she is.
Yummy, yummy.
Oh, yep.
That's not a child.
Where do I go?
Oh, that's not nice.
Oh, God.
It's okay.
She's afraid of the light.
The light is my...
Wow, what you gonna do now?
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, I remember you had to end.
Okay, I know I don't know what to do.
Now that I'm trapped in this room, what do I do?
Now that I'm trapped here, what do I do?
It'll be a shame if she comes and grabs me.
This is where I stopped watching.
This is where I started closing my eyes or looking away and
just let doobie do everything.
Which is not ideal.
Unfortunately, yes.
This is where I stopped.
I stopped watching her play.
It got too scary.
So I do not remember this is where God needs to take the
wheel.
Somebody needs to take the wheel.
That'll be fine.
Hey look.
Hey where is she?
Is that her?
Is that her over there?
Oh, that is her.
Oh, she possibly can't see me.
I'm down here.
No way she can crouch down.
That'd be stupid.
Wait, what did I pick up, or...
Alright.
It's alright.
Everything is fine.
Do this for him.
Toki, do it for him.
Do it for Leon.
You're doing this for him.
For Leon.
Doing it for him.
Oh, you're doing it for him.
For Leon.
Okay.
be strong be strong for leon be
okay where is she really she won't come back right
surely she won't come back so far away do it for him Do it
for Leon
Oh my god you fucker Why die at an unimportant spot Where
the fuck do I go?
Wait what?
I don't remember what to do I look the way I turn around
Guys I'm I'm This is bad.
I legitimately don't remember what to do.
I looked away and let do me do everything else.
Oh!
I see it.
Oh my god.
Oh fuck.
It's fine.
Do it for him.
do it for leon oh my god the door do it for him do it for
him do it for him do it oh oh no no no
yay where is she
Where did she go?
Okay.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh.
No.
She was so fast that she didn't even see you.
where did she go she didn't even know i was there
oh she walked away nice god why are you so short
yeah yeah do it for leon do it for leon just remember how
badass it's gonna look just just remember how badass it's
gonna look when you get to go pew pew pew remember that
feeling dokey remember that feeling it was so cool yeah
okay all right do it for leah do it now i already interacted
with do it for him it was so cool toky remember how cool
that was okay wait
what happened wait a minute the hospital changed wait a
minute
Where did the...
Where did the corridor go?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wasn't there a hallway right here?
Wasn't there?
Okay.
Oh, turn right.
You're right.
Do it for the, uh...
Oh my god, it's right here.
I did not see that part.
You don't understand.
I'm not okay right now.
Okay.
I don't know what to do.
I'm right here, bitch.
You see that?
That's right.
That's...
Oh my god, it's the door again.
Oh my god, please, Grace.
Oh my god, I'm so slow.
I...
She's so slow.
What the fuck?
No!
Oh my god, I'm freaking out.
I'm freaking out right now.
Surely, surely she chased me too far.
Do it for Leon.
Do it for Leon!
Do it for him!
Do it!
Okay, okay, okay, okay I've done it.
I did it for Leon.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
It's okay.
Why did I...
Do it for him.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We made!
Okay, let's see.
We made.
Let's get...
Okay.
It's okay, stop falling, Grace!
I mean, I mean, I did it.
I did it for him.
Grace, you...
No!
It was right there!
He can't do this to me!
I was right there.
Bro,
she cheated!
I was told that she was afraid of lights.
What the fuck just happened?
Oh my god, finally.
I went through hell.
I went through hell for him.
The promises he didn't.
Doki, she died as she lived a snack.
Leon was cool-ass, poorish.
It's time.
Volume up.
Now I can up my volume again.
And that was the end of...
That was the end of the demo.
Now I actually don't know what's going to happen.
Thank God.
I'm so happy that the demo was that hospital part because it
would have been so much worse it was bad still but like it
would have been really really bad mr kennedy welcome dr
gideon has been expecting that's true if grace dies you
don't have to play as her invitation well he's waiting for
you you're right i hope the monster eats her follow me
please gus thank you for the super chat that you're so right
End her now.
Finish her.
So how long have you worked for a Dr. Gideon?
Not long.
That is so cool.
I just recently joined the team.
Oh my god.
Look at that.
I don't care if there are zombies.
I have the entire United States armory right out in my
pocket.
all started stored in my gene pocket
experimental therapy gee i hope that clearly that man is
very much alive these surely they're all very much alive
people under these under these blankets That's right.
I'm exploring.
No fear here.
Gonna climb up.
Gonna look through your things.
Gonna see.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh, I can...
That's the loot right there.
Yeah, these corpses will definitely not start moving again.
And I definitely don't have to go there and grab a loot
later.
you're just covering their heads because the lights are on
it's right here is it doky show you're not locked in there
with them they're locked in there with me star thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you was there a difficulty
option at start yeah the difficulty was like play like a
pussy um to just enjoy the story play normally which we
picked or like make it play it play normally but also very
very limited saves
oh hey there's that guy there's the the crazy guy on matt
victor right see i processed the story
i remember his name code six code six all staff initiate
emergency protocols emergency protocols oh no are the people
wake up immediately what's going on yeah what's happening
some kind of mass hysteria the hospital is on lockdown oh
hey little doctor don't make me call hr on you please doctor
not in front of the patient oh oh okay yeah yeah okay don't
bump oh well all right this is a different hr call
weapons now oh wait they've always had weapons back resident
evil 4 time it's throwback
oh shit it still works it's oh wait that's a different lady
when she has her own chainsaw when she grabbed the chainsaw
how is that possible but don't let him near the chainsaw
apparently they could just grab it as fucking legal there's
requiem oh my god I swear to god are you oh my god oh my god
I reload the gun don't worry we're five got it stuck like a
video oh shit okay five okay now I should be able to grab
this right don't let me grab it okay this is unfair oh my
god reload okay that's fine okay there we go I just stupid
chainsaw the chainsaw has more fucking kills than me okay
now now it's my chainsaw I think the chainsaw has got me
more afk there we go there we go that's right now it's my
turn okay everyone everyone can use the chainsaw but me
apparently that's okay give me back my chainsaw Jesus Christ
yeah chainsaw is MVP for most assist are you fucking getting
me oh my god are you kidding me what do you mean oh no okay
it's okay she's too weak she threw the chainsaw okay
okay my turn
all right is everyone dead now um All right, get out of the
room.
Okay, I can finally leave.
I...
Everyone wants to turn on this chainsaw.
All right, there you go.
Unlimit.
Why need gun when I have chainsaw?
All right, I remember where the loot is.
Damn.
These chainsaws are whole...
see guys we don't have to cure a butt ammo it's
fine we don't need to save ammo we're leon ammo comes to me
all right are these bodies gonna get up i have a chainsaw do
they also want to have a turn on the chainsaw too do you
guys want to also touch the chainsaw?
Apparently, this chainsaw is a fucking slut.
Everyone wants to touch it.
Alright.
Here we go.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
No!
My chainsaw!
Oh, now it's broken.
Alright.
oh now it's broken it's fine it's fine i don't need it i
have an axe
all right what the fuck fine let's break this oh it's
achievement hunter time hey good thing the chainsaw didn't
snap and hit honestly i'm surprised i am very surprised
actually did not do that the fact that the chainsaw hit me
more afk than from people using it i just hacked into the
center's network good good i'll see what i can do well in
the meantime i'll try to track him down keep me posted we'll
do it was alive oh wait oh this is where this is where Where
is she supposed to be?
Grace's.
I hope Grace's dead.
I don't care if she's immune.
I don't fucking care.
Oh, oh.
Oh, it was happening at the same time.
Leo, why didn't you...
Actually, no, it's good that he didn't do anything.
It's okay.
It's good.
No.
Hey, over here.
why did you have to be a hero no
the one time the one time did ashley not teach you anything
leon you okay yeah thanks leon kennedy dso
No way it was that easy to kill her.
Grace, what is the point, Grace?
If someone kidnapped me.
Victor, get in.
I don't know.
Well, we should leave.
No, no, no.
Please, please.
I just, please.
I just, you can't give me like five minutes of Leon and 30
minutes of grace.
Please, this isn't fair.
What happened to Equal?
rights please what happened to equal rights they can't do
this to me i i can't have five minutes of leon and 30
minutes of grace take this oh that's cool it had like six
bullets in there right yeah i only i shot one time get out
of here i should have six bullets in there so at least at
least i can finally defend myself six times please please
let me play leon please come on she won't get away you know
oh hey victory
no you can't say that those are cutscene bullets cutscene
bullets never count you can't say that cutscene bullets are
not real they progress the plot why don't we have a little
talk And then I get the...
Holy shit, he's so tall!
Oh!
Wait!
You're exhibiting symptoms too.
No!
No, I'm special!
I'm Leon!
No!
He can't do this!
That's my idol!
he's supposed to be invincible no
it's okay he's just pretending he's faking guys god they
can't do this to me oh my i only get to be leon for five
minutes what was it people were like save your abba i was
like you guys there's as leon there's no such thing as
saving ammo.
It's like literally raining bullets.
No.
You can't.
Why give me a gun at all?
Why?
Like at least at least throw.
It's just cosmetics.
It's just purely cosmetic.
But surely there's ammo in.
Surely there's ammo here and why there's why why give me
hope what's the point like actually what's the point but
like is this rage bait am i am i getting am i is he rage
baiting me
here take a look at the sick ass gun
Here, you need to defend yourself one bullet.
Leon, what the fuck?
Why didn't you give me your other gun that has 40 bullets?
Okay, listen.
He had a choice of giving her a gun with 40 bullets or a gun
with one bullet for the person that clearly is very helpless
defend a guy who by the way has one axe one crowbar and also
he had a chainsaw before
oh leon you're so silly he's just being silly yeah it's a
big bullet
all right in fairness it's his best gun
a lady who oh is this a safe room where's my typewriter okay
thank god all right let me what can I put in my storage this
one gun ain't gonna do anything that's for sure I might as
well what's the point I might as well put this gun in
storage what's the point of having it thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you he gave you an easy way out
all right folders marked with recent dates it's for
emergencies
in exchange for prizes in the parlor oh yippee there's
there's many games i told her chef that you're a full course
meal he now wants to serve chicken breast for dinner and
you're the whole chicken done even the super chat thank you
that he looks so evil like i i don't know like if like i i
don't know like if i i don't know like if i saw some guy
that's i don't know if i saw him with those types of eyes i
don't know if i want to give him the director's spot yeah
that like i don't know maybe they're like that's fucked up
because you're that's discrimination and i'm like his eyes
are black like maybe that's god's way of telling you to not
hire him like
it's like it's just a skin condition dokey that's
discrimination and we don't, I'm, his eyes are black.
Don't judge how book by its cover.
See, I say never lie.
You can't discriminate against demons.
You need a moon, trust of the sun, secure it.
We are partners.
All right, here we go.
Just because his eyes are black doesn't mean he's a bad guy.
But it's just coincidence that his eyes were black with
glowing yellow eyes and he happened to be evil.
There was no correlation whatsoever.
And it looked like he never seen the sun before in his life.
don't worry surely he won't be evil there's no there's the
correlation does not lead to causation guys science he's
just lacking vitamin d what's the point i i stored the gun
there's no point this that's just leon fucking with me
medication room like what even was the point of holding on
to that fucking gun
doesn't have enough blood, Doki.
Truly, I can open this door.
Even inventory space is more useful than the gun.
Oh.
She seems not evil.
See, guys?
Her eyes aren't...
Her eyes aren't demonized.
She's just blind.
She can't be blind and evil.
Y'all pick one.
I'm sorry if I...
Surprised you.
Yeah.
You can't see, can you?
Who are you?
Was there someone in the other cell?
Oh, wait, what happened?
Yeah, there's a whole...
there.
Wait, there is a hole.
Where did they go?
Oh shit.
Oh no, he's turning.
It's okay.
He can't do anything.
The safe room is literally right next to me.
Wait, why?
Wait, is he not gonna turn?
He's gonna be like, oh, got your finger.
The fact that she was so close to him, too, she has, like,
no survival instincts.
She's just like me, for real.
He's like, oh, my God.
This guy who clearly looks very infected.
Let me put my finger right next to his mouth.
Open the door.
I'm gonna open this door.
She seems like a good person.
The skin was gouged by something sharp.
Blood everywhere.
But if I open this door first.
Oh.
Oh, it's just a west wing.
Hello.
You wanna talk?
Nice.
Alright, guys.
I don't need batteries.
I should be fine.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, it's so many people's birthdays.
What's...
What month?
What month would that be?
Brady, but Brady, happy birthday!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What holiday baby are you?
Brady, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yesterday was my birthday, Kat.
Please get a happy birthday.
Of course!
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday dear Frady, happy
birthday to you, yeah, happy birthday.
Oh, you're a, are you an America baby?
Or have, what, happy mother's, I'm, happy mother's day, it's
time to make you a mother.
all right it's time to go out all right i need to know is it
worth holding the gut phoenix thank you for the five gifted
chips thank you thank you that's sad there was so many
birthdays today i was curious guys weren't you It was even a
cat's birthday.
But cats are not nine months, though.
I think I like saying happy birthday like at least five
times today.
That's a record.
That's actually a record.
The most happy birthdays we got today.
Masha, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got your version of what controller yesterday looks great
and feels great.
Thanks for having them as a merch.
heck of it.
They give it a super chat.
Thank you.
It's a world record.
Alright.
I'm glad.
I'm glad the controller arrived.
But what's over there?
I swear to God if it's a...
Oh wait, no.
That's where...
Check your corners, everyone.
Corner check.
It's the only thing that Valorant taught me.
Only useful thing.
Okay.
no it's one what the am i gonna do like that one bullet is
for emergency only
all right
it's my pet rocks rockington's formation day can you sing
him a happy formation song thank you for the super chat star
thank you thank you silly star rocks have no rights
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What a no key.
They have no soul.
But I don't have that.
That's the horse door.
Oh my god.
Am I just going to be running around like a little bitch
with the zombies?
I am going I'm aren't I Are the herbs just all for me Oh my
god Don't my I hate you Grace I hate you I hate you I hate
you I hate you I do it for Leon Do it I do it
I can't even sharpen my fucking flashlight
do it for leon
oh my god i can't please at least let me pick up a pad
please leon had a funky crowbar at least let me pick up the
pad oh my this is bullshit let me open the oh hello hey No
goodbye, I swear.
Like what am I supposed to just run away?
Oh, is she coming over?
Hello?
You gonna...
All right, let's do this.
Take two.
God, grace, I hate you.
Is he chopping again?
All right.
All right, chop, chop.
Chop, chop.
I hate you so much.
I fucking...
Oh, my God, I hate you.
What is he gonna do?
Oh!
Wait, that's not good.
I just moved this forward?
Oh my god, Grace, I hate you.
I hate you, I hate you, Grace.
I hate you.
Oh, my God.
30 minutes of grace and five minutes, Leon.
This is sexism.
I demand equal playtime as both characters.
If I get 30 minutes of grace, I should get 30 minutes of
Leon.
I demand equality.
I had cutscenes longer than my playtime as Leon.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I assume I have to push the cart all the way to the end.
Next is what?
No way he sees me.
What the fuck?
What are you doing?
Do I push it or pull it?
Guys, I can't tell.
I'm too scared right now.
Guys, we gotta get through Grace's part together.
We have to get through.
through her part together wait we do it next next next one
okay the second next one all right the second next one guys
okay the third next one
no way he sees me
Okay.
After he sniffs.
Why can't you push this faster?
Like, I don't understand!
Oh, my God.
I can't have any.
I I actually can't have anything in this world I I hate her
I I legit you can't can't even build a relationship with
this character I do you not have to do a physical exam at
the FBI how how do you you oh my god i think i actually
legitimately hate this character i you can't just give me
leon and her at the same time i i fucking
go for that shit
Oh Wow Oh shit Oh shit It's okay I can Do that and then I'll
just do that and then And then oh my god Again Chris God
just fight Oh Oh my god Oh my god Please tell me, Doris.
I, I, I'm so, I'm so mad.
I'm so mad.
I'm trying.
Why?
That's just, you can't just, there's no ammo.
What do you mean?
There's no ammo.
Wait.
I thought, I thought that was ammo on the floor.
my god oh my god i thought oh thank you thank you all right
two bullets oh thank you leon got 800 and then she gets two
that that's fair leon finds the entire united states armory
but grace gets two whole bullets
surely oh my god thank god all right date i take those i'll
take eight eight is better than two that's a higher number
oh my god grace oh oh my god the one time you're strong the
one time oh my please don't get up oh what do you mean you
got up oh
she's so weak I hate you.
Oh, what the fuck?
Hello?
Oh.
Really?
I'll just grab that.
And then I'll just walk over here.
How many?
many zombies are here oh my god there's zombies everywhere
is that a siren there's oh fuck
it oh fuck it i must be able to open this oh hey there's
there's a oh all right that's that's okay surely this is a
safe area where nothing scary is gonna get me oh puzzle time
what what am i supposed to do with this puzzle okay puzzle
time oh my god it's a password oh my god it's for blind
people okay clearly i don't have a solution for this
password the new hire showed a promise at the dinner meeting
last month have his clearance bumped up a level and get him
set up to work on the project send the current researcher
for processing while you're at it okay oh my god i hear so
many zombies okay you're fired oh pencil doesn't see me
right what if I shank his ass
oh my god please tell me I can combine you
Why won't you come by?
Okay.
Come by.
Oh, come by.
There we go.
Come by.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'll shank him.
Watch this.
See?
look at that see that knife i hope i didn't just waste that
durability because that would have been so awkward
re-hit oh my grace i grace you had one job grace you really
had one job
Give me your bottle, oh my, get out of here.
Give me your bottle.
Selfie, oh my god, I don't even get his bottle.
I need to like it.
It's okay, I never needed it.
I didn't even give it the rain.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
I never needed the bottle.
okay we received i want to enact code six i have achieved my
goal and no longer have any need of this place all right
that's cool he the bottle broke grace you're a mess we're a
mess i i don't know what to do anymore grace
grace we are both hopeless It was just meant to be.
I stabbed.
I missed.
I missed again.
It was fine.
Oh, my God.
There was a light here all along.
All right.
Obviously.
Moon.
Sun.
Star.
Moon.
Moon, sun, star, moon.
All right.
That's easy.
Moon, sun, star, moon.
All right.
Moon.
star moon all right we got the moon quartz okay oh i'm gonna
be here for a while
oh my god
if i'm gonna be stealthing the entire game
I could have been playing Silent Hill
Oh my god Don't do this Alright, it's fine Come by
Okay, maybe I can kill her No, I don't think so
Maybe I can kill the siren with this I have to get the hell
out of here But the whole building is locked down I need to
ask the chairman to get his courts For me I just heard
another scream My colleagues are killing each other What the
fuck is going on?
I don't even know where I am I think she saw me No
I don't know where I ran off to I I kept running and then I
progressed somehow.
Shake!
There we go.
Oh my god, please tell me.
Okay, I don't care.
I need you to be dead.
I need you.
I don't care.
I...
I think they hurt me.
oh it's okay i hate this place okay okay i don't care if i
don't care if like my thing is about to break i need to be
out of here i i i don't care i just want to be out of there
all right i don't care if she heard me she still she won't
leave that area if i don't know stuck there.
They can't get into the main lobby until they can.
But that's future Doki's problems.
Future Doki can worry about that.
Alright.
What?
I don't think I need this.
It's like the police station.
They can't get in until they can.
And I'm going all in.
Oh hey, look.
You're still dead.
Hey.
Are you all right?
You're the lady from before.
Yeah, that's me.
This is...
But Doki will be for future Doki.
Not yet.
I still have time.
I still have time before it hits.
Because I can't see.
Oh no, no.
That's um...
That's not what I've been...
It's not my fault.
What?
Being blind?
The doctors gave us both medicine.
Made our eyes go bad.
Wait, was La Yerona?
Her?
And then she got bigger?
There's another bed in this...
My friend.
Marie.
Wait, was Marie the girl we killed?
One day she just...
Disappeared.
They're wearing the same dress.
I'm sorry.
When it happened, I was happy it wasn't me.
Oh no.
Is that bad?
Huh?
I think we killed her friend, but she doesn't know that.
I didn't kill her friend.
Leon killed her friend.
So she won't be mad when she finds out.
out I think Leurona was her because like they were wearing
the same dress oh my God she got big yeah holy shit look at
Tati that hole was look how look how big she became she
doesn't know that and she'll never know the truth dies with
me and Leon.
Yeah, I'm gonna do the double save.
I don't trust myself.
Alright, here we go.
Back at it again.
Okay, from what I remember, the unicorn room.
Wait, can I go through here?
Do I have...
Oh, this card only works for one room.
Okay.
Oh, she's not evil, guys.
She's not evil.
it should be fine it's only the chop chop man and the chop
chop it's okay it's okay oh it's no longer okay shit
surely the chop chop man doesn't see me right
surely Where is he going to walk to?
Okay, that is just unfair.
Come on.
What's he going to do?
Come out of here?
This is the lobby.
That's illegal.
Chop, chop, man.
What the fuck?
Did it not like that?
Damn.
Okay.
Not a dinner time yet, guys.
You turn around that.
Now that's legal.
You turn around.
Dinner time.
Wait, how long?
How far does he do that for?
That's cheating.
They have a set pathway.
Okay, he turns around here.
Where did he go?
Okay.
This is unfair.
What the fuck?
I don't have that bottle, guys.
That is not fair.
I repeat.
Oh my god, it's Gamma.
Did I close the door?
Please let me... Okay, there you go.
I just don't want to be there.
Is it Gamma time?
Gamma.
Did I win?
How do I gamble?
I would like to gamble, please.
What's the point?
What's the point in my cat?
Why is the light switch clicking?
I mean, there's prizes here.
Why can't I open it?
Four foot.
What's the point?
Can't just give this to me and I can't indulge.
Please.
The point is gambling is bad.
You need...
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
No, I have the coins here.
Okay.
I have the coin.
Let me bet.
Let me gamble.
The coin is literally right here.
Oh, is this the...
Oh, okay.
Wait.
What is this?
Hip pouch allows me to carry items.
Wait, stable...
I don't need a stabilizer.
A pure skill.
What is this?
Increase the blood collector's capacity.
what's that what's blood collector
what the fuck is the blood collector when the fuck would I
need a gadget for later oh you collect to collect blood
alright I'll insert it oh my god it's four coins I didn't
read I thought that's where I make the bets I don't i
thought it's like oh that's where i decide the number it's
gonna land on okay never mind
oh dokey now it's like oh that's where that's how i make my
gamba that's how i do it all right another coin he's gonna
he's gonna
case i broke it it was worth it east wing oh sorry about
this it was worth it i broke my one weapon
i just i had to double tap he could have been alive you
don't understand He could have been alive.
And then what's going to happen to me?
I don't...
Yeah, I said there was one more coin in here?
Where the fuck is the other coin?
God, grease.
Remember when I didn't have to conserve ammo?
Those were the good old days.
Oh, in my storage?
Oh, I thought you meant in this room.
Shoot your number and then use the roulette.
What do I win?
Guys.
Oh, Mike.
Do I win anything?
Core?
Alright.
The satisfaction of winning.
Well.
this looks so breakable i don't know i don't have anything
to break it with
okay all right
i actually win a coin chat i don't have my knife i used on
that one guy run brush i was like is he alive and i've used
my last swing just to shank him does it actually do i
actually get a coin
no okay there is a in that container?
There's no way.
I have nothing to break it with.
I'm not shooting this.
I am not shooting this.
There's no way there's a fucking coin in that container.
God
I...
Oh, I don't like that.
I hear him outside the door.
I...
I do not like that at all.
I don't...
One bullet is worth the coin.
Alright.
I'm gonna do it.
I swear to God.
Oh my God.
He was right.
The one time I didn't get one guide.
The one time.
Oh my God.
We won the RNG.
I'm not playing with fucking court.
Fuck.
No, I'm not playing first person.
I already life is hard enough.
Life is fucking hard okay two more slots
oh my god run run run run run run back to my safe place back
to my safe place back to god an item time to save oh my god
oh my god okay okay we're okay maybe i can say hi to her
again Anything different?
No?
All right.
We have the card to the other side.
Oh, Leon, when will you wake up?
Leon, please.
Leon.
Oh.
What the fuck is that sound?
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh, everything needs a key.
Oh, it's this.
I can't hit it.
I can't even whack it with my fucking flashlight.
What's the point?
Oh, thank you.
Sorry, Leon took it already.
Alright.
There's a creature.
crazy man in this area he's to my left no it's over here
something under the shackle
all right
clearly he's not gonna turn around is oh my god i can't have
anything in here
a grace-only game this is practically a grace-only game this
beyond is just it's just a side quest
sd thank you for the super chat thank you this i can't have
i'm just on my own little fucking side quest why can't i the
front teeth go deep in the heart perhaps oh
okay How do I...
How does that work?
Oh, alright.
Oh, that's easy.
Oh, shit.
It's one.
It's...
Is it one use?
Is this one use?
What's the point?
Oh, fine.
He doesn't have an arm.
I can just loop him.
Is there anything else here?
What the fuck?
What's the point?
Oh, it's the door.
I was like, what's the point of being here?
The door.
Oh.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh my god, he's still here.
Surely there's loot, right?
Okay.
All right.
The Kalex blood, which can be altered to craft other.
Use blood collector to gather, which can be used to...
You can increase your crafting of capabilities by analyzing
with the...
What the fuck?
Okay.
All right.
That's why I'm an analyst in the FBI.
Okay.
All right.
Finally.
I can use the skills I've gathered from the FBI.
Okay.
All right.
What the fuck is this?
Finally.
Okay.
all right this is all right you gotta infect which can be
okay you can cruise your crafting cables by analyzing all
right that's cool all right analyzing with a laser allows
your craft
finally going to college was not a mistake guys my degree is
useful putting the college degree to use i knew it okay i
can craft ammo all right all right let me try to do that
right now let me actually i could craft the injector thing
actually oh my god there's like zombies still in cross all
right what transform i'll add them oh there is a mutant
trying to kill me right now but let me give me a sec let me
transform these these let me do this mini game Okay.
How do I craft it?
All right, so that's what the bucket is for.
Okay, that makes a lot more, I can inject more.
That is an entire bucket of, you can't fucking tell me that
it had no more blood.
You, that is an entire bucket of blood and grease stops.
I was skeptical at first, but I'm genuinely impressed by its
effectiveness.
Combining effective blood with experimental substances has
been such a challenge for her, but using this device makes
it so easy to ensure to improve the efficiency of our blood
research and speed up analysis for further mutated patterns
this okay all right that's fine let's analyze this blood oh
does that have to be a hundred for me to analyze when can i
start crafting uh chain combined okay
which I feel like handgun ammo right I don't know I don't
know if like didn't I don't feel I don't know if the
injector is like worth it I feel like ammo is more worth it
because I can just shoot them in the knee that one shot item
is good but like but like they're these guys unless like But
like these guys are like weak as hell Like they're just
regular zombies Can I use the injector on the chop chop guy?
Yeah, I was thinking Can I use them on big bot?
Okay, but how the fuck do I Can I use it on the chef?
Oh, they drop coins?
I like money That's worth it God damn it
Alright Alright, we'll save that for chop chop man Alright,
we'll save that for chop man Surely he's not over there,
right?
I just want to shoot this one guy.
Oh,
no.
Oh, I don't like it.
Oh, no!
Um.
Don't see me, right?
Why is she walking towards me?
I
got out I thought I got away I thought I was so smart oh I
thought that is not good oh no oh no oh hey oh yeah where am
I oh no I don't know where I am where am I okay I'm back
here all right time to save my game that was not a good
place to be not the face it's okay i'm immune all right
hello i thought i would get another cutscene like last time
all right there's no time to look at the map guys i'm
panicking okay all right i know there was a lot of blood
around me all right there is blood here there is blood here
oh my god we're okay um we're we're like a pantry okay oh my
god okay um all right i do not have any of this organless
corpse what the fuck am i supposed to do with organless
corpse there's a coin here there's there's an upstairs okay
but do i go i guess i go upstairs okay i go upstairs i okay
all right it's fine okay all right back to hell i don't
worry i'm ready i hear all of them over here
can sneak now.
Alright.
We go out.
Panic attack done.
I'm all better now.
Okay, they can't just do it now.
And then give me nothing.
Let's go, girl.
Give me nothing.
I'm sure I just want to shoot her.
Alright.
All right, we'll be updating the following safes in the
facility.
Marine safe will be replaced at a later date.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I'm not back here.
Just sniff that floor a little longer.
Ma'am, ma'am, there's nothing here.
Keep sniffing that blood.
All right, nice scraps.
All right.
I want to shoot her.
I really do.
Surely I'd be fine, right?
Okay, it's like she's literally blocking the only way.
Like, this other guy's not gonna move.
I don't know.
He's just standing there.
How many bullets?
I have 14.
Maybe she'll be done.
what if i just shoot it right okay it's okay i don't know
can i walk through okay i run here and then oh but there's
wait a minute oh that's the infected okay i run here and
then i go up okay it's okay guys we don't need the loot oh
my god i could i'm gonna shoot want to shoot her.
I don't care.
I'm gonna shoot her.
Her head is like literally right there.
Look at it.
It's literally right there.
Run.
Run, Grace.
You're so safe.
Like, what is she gonna do?
Run back?
Wait, actually?
All right.
What the fuck?
Oh, she walked back.
See, I told you it's five.
here.
Wait, that's illegal.
Wait, what if I... Guys, it's so... Oh my God.
Oh my God.
Oh
my God.
Oh my God.
I told you.
It's so... Wait, coin.
It's so free.
Oh my God, another coin.
Surely they won't chase me.
Surely.
Look at that.
Guys, I'm not a bad person.
I'm might have pushed oh guys
i'm not a bad person for pushing a patient he was a zombie
guys he he was a zombie i'm not a bad person i did not he
might have been injured but he was gonna kill he was gonna
bite me it was self-defense he was a zombie patient yes
What the fuck are they talking about?
Like, what am I supposed to do?
Wait, I have an idea.
Okay, this is...
I don't know what else to do.
Like...
Okay.
I got the map, though.
guys i'm not a bad person they were blocking the way they
were they were they were blocking the door i had my rights i
didn't say two for what i know my rights i am legally
allowed to push them if they the door is he okay moon wait
moon wait what is that the passcode that's the passcode oh
destroy the padlock this was my right away oh is that moon
sun star moon yeah moon sun wait no The last two is moon,
moon, sun.
Wait, what?
Oh, is it flipped?
Oh, that's for the moon.
This is the sun.
Oh my god, I'm so smart.
Which one's this?
This is the moon.
Okay, it's moon, sun at the end.
Oh, God, I'm so fucking smart.
Look at that.
Some would say I'm an analyst.
Okay, and then this.
Star, moon.
Okay, guys.
guys remember this star moon oh my gosh anything we're in
the back artificial organ transplantation experiment team
okay this is star moon sun star sun and then the last one is
star sun moon sun okay star sun moon sun i don't know this
work okay why can't you shoot it I misplaced the key for the
puzzle box none of the other executives must find it I need
you to locate it discreetly before next week's meeting if
you find it get the bottle corrosive from the conference
room and melt the lock off okay all right just gotta find
corrosive just I mean at least it's a hospital that that
should be easy enough luckily we're in a hospital it's not a
crime the own corrosive alright I have 7 I have 18 wait 14
more bullets
what?
Wow how does he I was gonna say oh my gosh you're on a
little date okay lock pick oh my god you can't do this I
can't do this okay here we go
all right all right okay there is a dead body right here
okay but it's dead dead all right we're gonna do this again
wait oh wait there's a time wait this is a safe room i feel
so safe okay this is a safe room wait i can push them
through the stairs
Watch this.
I'm gonna do it again.
Yeah!
Wait, what the fuck?
Yoink!
Oh fuck, I actually need- No, I am fucking- Okay, that is
fine.
Okay.
give me a sec i can't wait i can't wait no combine oh my god
but now i still don't have i still don't have room i still
don't have room
okay okay okay I'm okay all right it's okay I'll come back
safe room this is a safe room what do you mean this is not a
safe room what do you mean this is not safe
What do you mean?
Do not sin.
Okay, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I can grab infected blood.
And then, through infected blood, I...
Why are you not infected?
You mean you don't die?
Okay, I've remembered.
Oh no.
I...
This is...
Oh.
Oh no.
They don't...
They don't die.
What the fuck?
Turn around.
Oh, shit.
Guys, this is bad.
Guys, this is...
I don't give permission to...
I don't give Capcom permission to use my likeness in this
game.
I'm so thank you for this Super Chat.
Thank you.
Use, man, I wish I had...
the requiem gun right now oh no and i can't i can't even
burn the corpses i can't even burn the court oh no doesn't
turn around guys look at him what can i do he's literally
yes
oh my god wait there's another door
what oh it was just the wristband
this is bad
I have to make him chase me downstairs okay okay I gotta
remember okay nurse station I gotta be like okay okay wait
nurse station wait Where is, okay, okay, here we go.
All right, let's save again for good luck.
Let's save again for good luck.
Okay.
I need three, I guess, because I'm, you know, you know, it
makes sense that he needs three fucking injectors, you know,
that, but is he coming down?
Guys, he's coming down.
I don't know if he's Is he You know what I'm just You know
what I'm just I'm just I know what to do I surely this won't
fuck me over I swear to God I'm gonna Store all of this I I
swear to god this is what this is what this gunner is for
this is truly truly truly a monster that takes three
injectors would not would take one one bullet surely don't
miss don't miss no pressure no pressure no pressure at all
just don't miss
one bullet one kill
oh I oh that's true I can get the upgrade alright let's put
this store uh
Yeah, I'm gonna grab the upgrades.
Well, I'm gonna grab the upgrades.
I'm gonna make sure I don't accidentally shoot my gun.
Oh, I'm using this injector to kill the chop chop man.
He's here.
Let's get chop chop man out of here.
Chop chop.
Where is chop chop man?
Chop chop?
Chop.
Chop chop.
I don't like that chop chop man disappeared.
Is that him?
Chop chop.
Yeah, but I don't know.
He doesn't see me.
Because he's stupid.
Jesus!
Goodbye, chop chop.
Yeah.
oh key oh nice wait but that's not what i wanted wait why
can't i take his blood hello where are your blood at
teleport's behind you but he doesn't have blood i i
literally exploded wait that's where am i oh my god he
turned around he made me turn around which made me turn
around which now here okay this way on the wall why can't i
suck the blood oh my god
what's the point i get he has so much blood
it's just all blood but it doesn't I don't think I need a
stabilizer.
Wait, which one should I get?
I'd like this one, right?
No, I don't need that.
Which is better?
This?
The stabilizer?
Oh, stabilizer damage.
Yeah, that is better.
I'm getting damage.
Can I do this faster?
Oh my god, I can't.
It's just like I might.
one by one all right that's good all right which was best
the capacity or I feel like max out does not fucking matter
I'm gonna get okay it doesn't matter I only have three all
right uh we'll just put it all in just put it all in all in
I might as well just so I have more inventory space I can
inject myself Is it permanent?
Oh, it is.
Bye, chop, chop, man.
Guys, imagine if I had a wristband right now.
Imagine if I had a wristband right now.
That would be pretty wild.
be crazy i had storage for a fucking wristband and crazy
stuff though so fucking crazy all right i have enough for
another injector
i still see the blood he's gonna cook the soup now
okay this better be fucking loot i swear to get oh my god
his blood okay I can make more oh yeah now I can hit shit I
can make two okay I'll make two injectors it's
fine and then oh wait I have okay but I can't stealth him
though that's the worst part it's this powerful large from
the sheer mass developed oh Oh my god, now I have...
Oh, nice enough.
Takeout.
Increase this knife, pal.
I wish I have a knife for this charm.
I wish I have.
How the fuck do I put it on?
Oh, just by holding it.
Okay, that's two.
That's big gun.
Big boy ammo.
Now I have two bullets.
Dude.
Now I have two holy bullets.
Alright.
Where?
I can craft knives?
How?
Explain.
Oh.
Don't need to explain.
I figured it out.
I need...
Okay.
I need scrap to make a makeshift knife.
I'm so smart.
If only I didn't use the scrap to make another injector.
Okay.
If only...
It's okay.
Chop, chop, man, there's no more.
I can freely roam the halls.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh my god, that means I have to go through the nurse's
office again.
So I can bait him around.
Okay, it's fun.
It's fun.
I have two bullets now.
And then...
And I'll bring this over here.
And then I'll reload.
And then.
And then I put the gun away.
All right.
All right, there we go.
I don't even remember which was which save.
I'm just going to keep creating new save files.
okay before i do anything why won't she talk to me she
talked to me once and now she doesn't care oh wait nice nice
you were useful you were actually useful for something okay
all
right save again all right okay before i go to big boy i
need to know this can he die from one requiem bullet this is
not spoilers guys i only have two bullets guys i only have
two so this is very important okay not what see see guys
it's great when you guys don't troll me
i do not my resources are very very limited oh my god rare
metal what can i make with that nothing
all right no help all right let's save let's put this away
maybe I'll be able to have three bullets let me put this
away all right all right here we go again I wonder Oh my
god, please don't tell me I have to loop all the way around
Where is he?
Okay Okay, that's nice Wait, that is not nice
Wait, I did that
Okay Okay Okay.
Okay.
Wait, there should be like...
Oh, but it's full.
Oh, please don't tell me you'll come back up.
I just want my room.
I know I should get the corrosive, but like...
But like, Luke...
Oh, okay, remember, 30, right?
oh wait 30 right 10 left 50 right okay that means wait guys
okay i have to i'm gonna make this that's three and i can
grab more no way he comes back
oh is that the siren
where is she wait where is she Oh god.
Oh god.
I don't...
How?
oh my god i'm just gonna kill you i don't care i don't care
i don't care fuck you worth it oh not that though not that
oh not that though whoa whoa whoa
Wait, did I get the corrosive?
I did not get the corrosive.
That wasn't worth it, though.
Whoa.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
I'm home.
Oh, my God.
Word up.
That's over there.
It's over there.
Okay, co-hosted.
Boom.
Oh, shit.
Not good.
I am not okay.
I am not good.
Not good.
Not very good.
Oh, no.
Not good.
Very much not healthy.
But it's okay.
That boy isn't here.
And the zombies, they didn't come back.
And then...
Oh, my God.
I'm not okay.
Oh.
Okay.
Calm down.
Calm.
down just need a oh you're just having a really bad day
grace it's just just one bad day it's okay it's just a very
very long bad day how are you oh forgive me there's no way
he's gonna kill me I'm like his project it'll be a waste
there's no way keep all that effort just to kill me right
here I know you need me why else would you keep her alive
she's so pathetic she's just like me
unique through you help us can finally be Elpis?
What the fuck is...
Why me?
I have no idea if I'm making a lot of progress or not.
I'm just...
I'm going off pure instinct right now.
I just...
I'm just following my heart.
Oh.
Phase 2 is about to begin.
I love Elvis.
Elvis Presley?
oh wait who's that
oh he's mutating from the virus would you like to see what's
hidden under the hood
can't do this i brace brace you can't do this to me I worked
so hard to get there.
Oh,
she baited him.
That was smart, yeah.
That was smart.
Good thinking.
Like, boo.
Thank God I didn't have to play that.
Thank God that was all in a cutscene.
never thought of that thank fucking god i would have never
thought of that holy shit i'm not okay right now what the
fuck does he mean i am not okay
clever girl okay guys do you guys remember all right just in
case you fuck with me okay Star Sun Moon Sun Okay Star Sun
Moon Sun Okay so you guys type boobs Okay Star Sun Moon Sun
Nice Yeah I got another notebook Everyone does notebooks Ooh
The organs transport box all right hand middle up down up up
down auto that seems easy enough victor here in documents a
theory that uses a t virus to control memories and will this
for recovery candy for my post yeah i need that thank you
for the super chat hell thank you thank you the research
shall serve as a guiding light for all of humanity in rare
instances repeated mutations of the t virus can trigger an
abnormal reaction in an infected individual's body leading
to changes in their blood the mutated strains of the t virus
will luckily sweep the world and total eradication will be
impossible those infected by the mutated t virus strain and
characteristics blood transformation within this lies the
key to humanity's evolution okay okay so that's why some of
them were like cleaning and stuff because they have the
mutated t virus so so he sees this as the next form of human
evolution i see so he's using a mutated um the mutated virus
for this it's like super covid
Okay, now the sun quartz.
I need one more, right?
I don't remember.
I just need one more.
See.
You know what's crazy?
Evolution has the word evil in it.
Coincidence?
I think not.
So true.
Whoa.
Oh
my god, Grace Alright, let's hope I can walk downstairs With
a big fat baby chasing me
Oh, she is really fucked up right now
I don't like her I don't like her fucking Like I think I can
literally just run past this.
All right, goodbye.
I'm going to go take my meds.
I got to go take my meds.
Oh, no.
All right.
I made it.
I can't believe it's been...
How long have I been playing this already?
I can't... It doesn't even tell me how many hours.
But I've already saved 18 times.
three hours and i already made 18 saves just as just as they
intended okay i think i can actually i need that uh
all right i'm just gonna i'm just gonna store my one bullet
surely that one bullet is not needed so i can use this and
then wait actually what am i gonna do with this is that it
oh this is it for this i don't need that and i have chat all
right guys screenshot this when we're there i need inventory
space wait what what
happened to my other gun wait no oh wait i wasn't okay i was
like what happened okay store this streamer privilege
use this juice up grace you need it all right uh
yeah i can i can use my coins right now as well i don't know
where the fuck the thing is for the for the court stuff i
don't remember guys i've been flight or flight response this
entire time she want to talk now how girl oh she's doodling
all right is it the front oh it's the front door i remember
it's right up here all right guys i looked at their door
like five seconds in the beginning of the game okay at least
we get rid of this we just need a star we need to find the
star room okay All right, there is the blood lab.
I don't think we're supposed to.
I think it's here.
It has to be here.
There's a garage.
The star room must be in the garage.
Where else could it be?
Right?
Right.
Child, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Okay.
We all remember.
All right.
Okay.
I wonder if Leon's having a good time like me right now.
I hope Leon's having just as much fun as I am.
All right.
Okay.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
I remember he had no organs.
He had no organs.
I'm like, I'm so virus.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
But I gotta get the upgrades.
Wait, actually, I don't have three yet, so it doesn't
matter.
I have two coins.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
He had no organs.
Where did his organ go?
I need to find the organ man.
Okay.
I'm sure I don't have to go here.
But Chop Chop Man's dead, so.
Can't be too bad.
No Chop Chop Man.
Nobody's defending the halls no more.
don't encounter big baby everything will be fine
all right all
right i'm not wasting my on you get out of here a course all
right you can take him okay sure
and a dream of shit all right if that leads to garage but
surely through the agent infrastructure construction a
garage will be carried out do not enter work area unless or
authorized the safe room yay okay oh fuck yes okay okay okay
okay okay oh fuck yes okay oh my god oh my god it's raining
it's raining loot i get one percent of what leon experiences
every day.
I... Okay.
It stinks of oil.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'll figure out what I don't need.
Okay.
I'm going to craft injectors.
Three injectors.
Don't worry.
Wait, actually I can make a knife.
Wait.
Fuck.
Okay.
need this i don't need that yet fuck i'm i'm oh wait i don't
need coins yeah you're right um do i make a knife you think
i can only make the shitty knife oh i can't i can't even
make a knife i'm it's useless i can't even it's okay i don't
need it
Sorteca.
Oh, wait.
I don't have a knife.
You're right.
Why am I holding this?
There's no game.
All right.
Yeah, I bet Leon could make a knife.
Must be nice.
Must pretty privilege right there.
Must be so nice.
Nice.
I don't know if I should make an injector.
Must be very knife.
Or ammo.
Oh wait, I think I'm fine.
I'll just store a storage just in case.
I don't trust myself.
Wait, what's downstairs?
Oh, they're upstairs.
Oh, nice.
I actually needed that.
I wish I could just...
I wish I could just, you know, just place it on top of the
other herb.
Hello?
Oh
Where the fuck oh
My god, I'm back here Wait, I can leave What if I just
leave?
Oh my god, this reminds me This feels so much like Which
Resident Evil 2?
I feel like I'm at the police station Okay, 10 left, 80
right, 30 left.
Oh, you more scraps.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck did I get?
Oh, file.
Okay, oh my god, it was not.
Yeah, like, this really feels like Resident Evil 2.
But, like, worse.
Because Grace can't do anything.
Yeah.
because she's not police trained
okay oh yeah because she i've seen i saw her push those
zombies and i was like oh grace you gotta hit the gym after
this yeah she's gonna be so buffed after this day is over
when she's finally home she's gonna take martial arts
lessons self-defense lessons she's gonna be so ripped right
after like
yes but she's an office she's an analyst it's like you're
you join like the secret service you're like in the was it
007 um you're james like leon is james bond and grace is q
you think q you think q can fucking stab anyone with those
noodle arms guys there to think not not the not to do soon
in resident evil 20 she's gonna be punching boulders
all right no way they heard me to smash that box right they
heard me
okay this guy's like
Let's go to the safe room.
We have so many options.
Guys, you know what I miss?
That fucking chainsaw.
That was a nice ass chainsaw we had there.
Oh, man.
Oh, I don't like this at all.
Maybe Ada will show up in the garage.
Ada?
Oh, I do not like this.
Oh, there's the thing.
Alright.
Here we go.
this this now what it's too quiet guys guys guys and in this
part i remember this up down up oh my god your chat was so
fast that i the one guy that gave me the answer okay and
then auto there we go you thought you try to hide him from
me but i saw it oh my you can't you can't you see okay all
right it looks like i'm making another injector it looks
like there we go
okay it's fine gonna break that box because i can oh i knew
i could do it oh my god wait that's great wait i had enough
for ammo oh my god life is good life is so good just in case
i feel like something's gonna start chasing me what
what give me a break
Okay.
All right.
I was like, there's no way.
It's too quiet.
It's too fucking quiet.
Oh, fuck.
I mean, the door is still unlocked.
But what if there's loot over here?
Boss defeated by doing absolutely nothing.
I mean, that was a sick ass.
She's getting better, guys.
She's learning.
She's actually growing.
Oh my god.
Guys, wait a minute.
This is character development.
Guys.
Oh my god.
This is trauma-bonding.
Before our eyes, we're slowly falling in love.
We hated each other.
But now look at us.
Oh my gosh, she's becoming a badass.
We're making progress.
Soon she'll be punching voters in no time.
All right.
I don't think I need the jar.
I don't think I need this.
I'm gonna put this away.
I'm beginning to believe, guys.
I think I'm beginning to see the light.
You ain't so bad, Grace.
Maybe there is a place for you and me in the apocalypse.
We just gotta work on your legs.
Wait, huh?
Where am I?
I'm just like, wait a minute.
Alright, that's the kitchen.
And none.
Wait, where the fuck is the...
Oh, it's here.
Yeah, we just gotta work on your...
On your leg game.
Twitchy, welcome to Tomato 4.
welcome welcome oh my god we're bonding we're getting to
know each other oh my god it was a bad first date but then i
gave her a chance and then maybe maybe i'm in love maybe
there's something in here maybe there was something here no
wait i have only two coin so there's no reason to spend it
ander thank you for the rate they could thank you i hope you
had a good stream oh wait what i don't like how i hear
i'm just gonna inject that's right surely they didn't hear
the giant ass noise all right and then i'll put the fake
lungs And then what?
Now what?
Oh.
And...
Alright.
Apparently, you need more than just lungs to be alive.
Apparently, you can't...
If you have no heart, You're dead.
You stay dead.
Who would have thought?
All right, which safe is this?
Guys.
Guys, which safe is this?
Wait, tab.
Which safe is that?
Oh, bar and lounge.
Okay, bar and lounge.
Do I have another one?
I found two other safes.
Where the fuck is the other safe?
oh examination 30 10 50 okay wait which way okay 30 oh my
god oh my god i messed up 30
10 50.
okay 30 10 50 there we go okay the oopsie there back one so
um where where is the heart i i don't remember are you why
is she here why are you here get out get out wait she did no
she's not dead go back go back to cleaning your ship's not
over if i have to keep doing my job you have to keep
more it's fine we'll come back later and she never came back
later guys I have to come back anyway I have to put the
heart in there guys I have to come back anyway guys that's
where the heart goes it's like my little reward after I get
the heart it's
like my little treat little treat i get like good job dokey
here's the heart for a job well done here's some coins
she never came back all right it's time to read okay nice i
read it okay now i'm lost i came out
i don't remember i don't know okay i don't know what to do
it's time to say to it for leon i'm it wasn't for the fact
that i missed i missed the dopamine boost of playing leon
part one would have ended already i that five minutes of
leon i want it back please that five minutes of leon it was
so good it felt so good for leon i need my five minutes of
leon okay corn cabinet antique coin where the is the heart
oh
my god there's only two floors of nothing
yeah but what if i do need it you don't know that one day
maybe one day It's gonna happen.
The heart is between your lungs, under, and under the
sternum.
The red valve!
The cold storage?
But I can't open that.
How the fuck do I open it, though?
There is this door.
But I don't know if that door is useful.
The waiting room?
No, because there's nothing there.
Oh, I have a wrench.
You're right.
Wait, does the wrench work for the cold storage shed?
Okay, I'll go there.
Do it for Leon.
The things I do for him.
I'm going to save again for good luck.
No elf.
Guys, this is streamer privilege.
I demand the privilege.
I yearn For the privilege Oh my god Why do I have the book I
thought I put you away Guys Do we not want to come back to
Leon Guys Guys Guys We gotta persevere Put Leon We have to
keep going Think of Leon chat think about leon do it for
leon also i need water i'll be right back guys
we're all here for leon all right here we go here we go okay
for leon i forgot word okay we okay i'm mapping it out in my
head I'm mapping it out.
All right, I'm ready.
Oh, God, please don't tell me.
Okay, dining room.
Okay, there you go.
I'm mapping it out.
I'm driving in my brain.
Oh, my God.
For Leon.
Okay.
Oh, blood.
Where's this?
Okay.
All right.
For Leon.
Do it for him.
Oh my god, that has to be loot, though.
Okay, wait, how much do...
Okay, I don't have inventory space.
Resist.
Resist the temptation.
Boom.
There we go.
For Leon.
Do it for him.
Okay.
What the loot?
We gotta keep the loot for Leon.
Okay.
Alright, there's the heart.
Turn it for Leon.
Guys, I can't.
I can't take all the loot.
Leon needs this more than me.
Leon.
Alright, get out.
here wait did i take it already oh i did all right enter
resist temptation
okay do not sin leon would not want this
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, but what if?
No, I don't have inventory.
Do not.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
Just this once.
Leon's not watching.
I can confess later.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I was not punished for my...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
No!
I'm sorry, Leon.
Please forgive me, forgive me, Leon, for I have sinned.
There you go.
Oh shit, is he dead dead?
Nah, still have his neck.
misspoke to leon knows of the sins you've committed i mean
i'm just gonna bye
okay please please leon i'm sorry i'm sorry i did not resist
temptation please forgive me
all right let's see all right it's fine we grab the key and
leon we trust
i'm sorry dear leon i'm sorry for not resisting the
temptation by now no the error of my ways amen
i hope that's the baby that's not close bye
Alright.
Now let me grab that coin as a celebration for a job well
done.
And then...
What?
Oh, that's not good.
Wait, wait, no, no!
Oh no, oh no, this is not good.
This is...
This is not good.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
It's fine.
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
It all worked out.
I didn't realize he just wanted to live five seconds long
but it brought him the life just for him to eat it's okay it
all worked out it all worked out black bone welcome to
tomato fire welcome welcome all right okay and then we go
here oh my god to be back here okay i didn't realize okay
okay i'm mapping it out in my head okay route route mapped
i'm driving in my head i'm driving in my head okay okay
route memorized there you go it's okay we don't need this
this just i've learned from my mistakes i shall resist
temptation leon almighty would not have wanted this for me
eventually their knees will eventually give out the amount
of times I have shot amount of times I have shot her
eventually her knees will give out like should that not be
the case like oh okay okay okay I was gonna be like that's
illegal what is
All right.
I'm just going to kick him.
And then he's going to be not scrubbing.
It's all right.
A nice change of pace.
Apparently the big baby is not next to me all right okay all
right isolation worry dad okay
this does not bring me joy
oh all right Gotta figure out where to go.
This does not seem like a very happy place to be right now.
There have been a number of cases where corpses infected
with a mutated T virus strain have exhibited rapid tissue.
Oh, that's why.
Oh, no wonder.
Every time I shoot him in the knee, they just regenerate
more ligaments.
That...
oh no that formed on the heads of these patient revealed oh
no they're back oh the red heads they're they're back oh oh
no okay all right all right that's cool that's nice welcome
back resident evil 2 look at the crimson heads they have the
worst part of resident evil oh i didn't welcome back my old
friend the band's back together we're having a reunion tour
Resident Evil 1, sorry.
They all blurs together.
Everyone's coming back.
My old.
I, guys, I didn't play Resident Evil 1.
I watched a lot of playthroughs, though.
All right.
Everyone is here.
Guys.
The reason why we even have this stream is because MSI has
monetized my parents.
in fear you you guys would not have got the stream from me
if it wasn't for msi
so remember to click on that link pin in the chat thank you
msi okay oh that's the blind girl She is emotionless and
unsettling.
This assignment fills me with unease.
Subject 171 is blind and quiesced a lot of assistance.
I felt sorry for her and tried to offer some comfort by
stroking her hair, but as always received no reaction.
Such an unnerving child.
I just want the same.
I'm ready for my mom to pick me up.
Doki, there have been a ton of top tier series review, but
this one was life-threatening.
I choked with Lact-Tor at least five times.
Thank you, Odin.
Thank you for the super chat.
you think i'm glad you guys are enjoying the series for some
reason the security manager joined me today he asked subject
171 two or three questions about blood but of course a child
wouldn't know how to respond what a strange oh what a
strange man what a weird weird guy oh man this is safe i'm a
little concerned that all right let's now that i know the
crimson heads are back let me craft let me let me oh let me
craft that all right are you a crimson head star star oh
star star moon sun he's dead or is he there's no way to
explain the crimson head and then like not they're gonna
come out aren't they
But the Braille is still visible.
Which buttons which?
Braille.
Don't tell me you're gonna be like, free the child so she
can read.
These girls.
Oh.
They look just like...
Yeah.
They're the blonde girls.
No.
I bet she can read that.
Please, I can just brute force this, Grace.
Why do you have to make this harder?
Just, just, just laugh.
Grace.
No.
just increase by the process of elimination we can figure
out we don't need a blind girl to read braille just increase
there is no way the entry level to the fbi has deteriorated
to the point that critical thinking is no longer potless no
longer applicable to join the fbi there What test did you-
Who did you know?
The eye agent, ladies and gentlemen.
There aren't that many.
The bar is very, very low.
Who- who was it?
Who got you here?
welcome back ashley ashley one and ashley two oh my god it's
funny to think that there must not exist terror films or
stories in this universe because they really don't know how
to trust the creepy child in the house you in the super chat
thank you thank you it's three buttons it's it's three
buttons grace it's it's every day every day you surprise me
you really do grace every second every second
of the blood she can't count a three it's very unfortunate
oh my god okay okay
i'm scared i don't know what the blister heads look like i'm
so scared i feel like i'm going to turn around that corner
and now blister up the blister heads just gonna be like oh
there
he is i could technically kill him right
No, I'm not gonna...
Maybe not.
Yeah, no.
No.
No, I...
I worried about the blister head.
And...
I see him just there.
And I was like...
No.
That's all right.
All right, I can go this way.
All right.
Look, I have to free the path.
I have Ashley 1 and Ashley 2.
Welcome back.
I thought I would never see you again.
Really?
I really thought it was over.
But it's never over, is it?
You always managed to come back, Ashley.
And now you're blind.
Where is Leon?
Where is Leon when you'd meet him?
It's been four hours.
I had three hours and fifty minutes.
of grace and 10 minutes of Leon.
Why did they put you in there?
I don't know.
If you close your eyes.
Do you mind if I come in?
I don't mind.
all right line girl i so um look i can't apparently i'm no
critical thinking skills i'm with the police and you are not
with the police you are a subcontractor
you are you were a subcontracted there is no way what's your
name
What if Ashley is blind?
Oh my god, that's even worse.
Do you think you could read something for me?
That's...
Oh my god, that is the worst possibility of an escort
mission.
I have a blind Ashley.
I'll take you there.
All right.
There are steps.
how about i carry you oh god oh god no oh god there must be
a way for don't know
no oh god push the buttons in this oh star star moon
Thanks.
All right.
Thank you.
Okay.
Some actions and attacks are impossible when you're carrying
Emily.
She can't stand.
She has, she's blind, not fucking.
She's blind, not in a fucking wheelchair.
The game was like, what if you get an Ashley that's blind
and can't even fucking stand?
This is literally, no, at least the pragmatic girl can fight
back.
Kane, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Holding my hand would be better than whatever the fuck this
is.
Because you know what happens if I hold her hand and just
got her to places?
My other hand can hold a second item, which means I can hold
a gun in my other hand.
She's blind, not fucking physically disabled.
Not a paraplegic.
Okay.
Rage being successful.
All right.
All right, little girl.
Let me...
Oh, I want to...
I want to shout so bad right now.
I think if I actually shout right...
You don't understand.
I'm restraining myself so fucking hard.
Because I think if I actually unleashed a double up right
now this girl is radiating me, I think my soundproofing
would not, I think it will blast through the soundproof.
I am so mad that I don't even think the soundproofing can
contain my anger right now to the, oh my, you have no idea
how much I am restraining myself right now and trying not to
yell at this little girl because not only am i carrying this
little girl i am physically unable to defend myself i okay
let me test the speed for leon for leon okay for leon okay
i'm testing the speed of this oh my god all right Let's do
another save for good luck.
Okay.
For Leon.
All right.
Okay.
Oh my god, the fucking blister head is gonna be here soon.
Poor Leon.
I have to keep it together.
Oh my god, I can't crouch.
I need you guys to know that I can't even crouch.
I...
Okay.
Poor Leon.
We're close now.
Oh.
I'm just...
What if I...
Just take it!
Don't worry.
It's okay.
Just take it.
For Leon.
Just... I...
No.
do the do the do do do this
and then leave her she is useless from men on she her
purpose has been served she has no no not that blister head
she has fulfilled her purpose
y 'all is the only thing keeping me oh my god I...
Okay.
Okay, I have gunned now.
Blisterhead.
Apparently he's gonna...
Oh, there it is.
There he is.
Is that him?
Okay.
Oh, fuck, that's not what I want to do, but that's fine.
Okay, I need him to get up.
I fucked up.
I for- I meleeed so much that let- Oh!
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
He's just a normal man.
That's okay.
Are you not...
It's three...
It's three buttons.
It...
Okay.
I will want to mention that it is three buttons.
It is.
Oh, fuck.
Help.
It's...
It's three buttons.
It's okay.
It's...
Don't worry, any second now.
Great state successful.
grace I did it oh oh thank you congratulations good you're
you are you are so smart little
no no why did you drop it why did it you drop it no why did
you just drop it just drop it Emily I'll Come back for you.
Just drop it.
Emily, I swear to God, I will come back.
I thought that thing was done.
No, you won't.
I'd come back for her, guys.
I swear to God, I would have came back for her if she just
dropped it.
If she just...
This is all my fault.
Emily did the right thing.
I can't just leave her.
Emily is smart.
She knew you wouldn't come back.
You don't know that.
That's a child, guys.
That's fucked up.
Are you saying I would abandon a blind child?
That's messed up, guys.
how could you see me like that oh oh oh there leon i never
doubted i never doubted i knew you'd be back leon oh my god
i persevered for you i volume back up yeah finally
we did it we did it for you we survived
the king returns space thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you or we can begin your treatment you know the
crazy part me and grace just fucking yolo that and brute
forced it it would be faster than where the fuck emily did i
stood there outside the door for at least a minute before
she cracked the code is this where i conduct my research
holy he's so cool he's he's so funny like my reward my
reward for the suffering grace and emily put me through this
is like victor's is like our victor is like our self insert
he's like yeah the last time you brush your teeth damn heck
enough oh
he's analyzing the infection how far off he is and you are
an ignorant god leon you're so cool with those one-liners no
flinch he's like i do that every tuesday you believe in
human evolution he does it so that he reinforces his skin to
studying it so his skin will be like rock hard so he can
have a little leon as a treat if i but the humans are
different than you think
it's like that guy he's like micro dosing eventually his
skin would be so tough that no knife can pierce the skin oh
my god did you give it to ask for it's time that's not an
herb leon that's gonna oh oh he's regenerating the wound you
see the little All right, the mold's got him.
I'm going to make my way to his office.
All right, how much bullets?
Oh, look at that.
Look at...
Where is he?
What the fuck?
What are these pockets?
All right, let's combine.
What the fuck?
He has the men.
Bro, man jeans, those pockets go deep, guys.
They're such a deep-ass deep pocket.
Yeah, Grace Ashcroft.
Man, you don't know how good you have it.
You think Grace has pockets on those pants?
I'm not intend to find out.
You don't know how good you have it, guys.
He's wearing cargo pants right now.
what is he wearing I like like oh there's no there's okay
okay one pocket two
all right here we go I do have an axe maybe I should not
have used my axe earlier but I do have it god he's so cool
you see the different type of gameplay we're having now that
we are Leon i mean you see it after surgical proceed
procedure to suppresses the center of the brain the subject
increased experience an increase in appetite and weight gain
he began to ingest any everything he could get his hands on
including infusion pumps and pacemakers this is the same
symptoms as his brother with a particularly strong fixation
on human flesh must be treated with extreme caution not
constantly eating.
Oh, that's the big guy.
Wait, is the other guy?
Wait, is Chop Chop his brother?
Wait.
Okay, one of...
Okay, no.
One of them is the is the big, big boy.
The big boy.
And apparently he has a brother, which not...
Which is not ideal.
Wait.
He's gonna punch...
He's gonna punch a ward.
the word oh my god i should have that's what the word tropes
are i just remembered the the ads oh my god i should have i
should have oh my god i should have unlocked the door for
him he deserves that loot that i knew it guys i knew i was
too greedy that loot was reserved that loot was reserved for
leon not for grace and fuzzy thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you everyone please be thankful that the
office ladies at capcom were involved in the dev process to
make sure leon remain as daddy as possible every single just
remember every wait what's that where shotgun shotgun shells
where every single wrinkle was purposely placed everything
was intentional
wait i can't shoot that there's the brother all right we
found the brother i've always wanted a brother wait let me
sharpen my axe real quick
all right wait
do i just oh i have to juke him don't i oh
he He does not care.
Joink.
All right.
I'm fine with that.
Hope I'm not next.
Wait, where do I have to have him destroy?
Which way is he going?
Oh, this way.
It's okay to stop.
That's stupid.
What do you mean?
that was not a time for that oh no oh that's not good am i
stuck no oh hot ground wait is this a boss fight
can't tell if this is up oh oh my god it is stay still
I felt that one, huh?
Oh my god, it's just that easy.
Oh my god.
Wait, how do I pick the high ground?
Guys, it may no longer be that easy.
Wait, can I just...
Oh.
Boink.
Oh, oh, oh, that's not good, Leon.
That is not good.
Don't worry.
And then I started blasting.
And I started blasting.
And I...
Okay.
It's fly.
That shall pierce it.
That pierces the... and then I start blasting.
And then I start blasting.
And then I reload.
And then he's mad.
He is mad.
Oh, he is so mad.
What are the whole more ships in there?
One more?
Truly.
Truly, the pistol will do something.
I have to die.
No.
don't worry i'll start blasting i'll start blasting me at
three oh god come on just break that one wall
hello where did you break okay okay
My...
Oh, hey, look.
Alright.
Oh, God.
Reload.
How much HP does this guy have?
Wait, which way did he go?
No!
We went around!
Okay, four more.
Four more bullets in the tree.
my my my i forgot i load one shotgun per shot
that has to be it that has to be it he's disintegrating
there we go that's right that oh that's a key
oh holy but i'm not on the menu my god that's crazy i
actually have one bullet left with my shotgun
all right leon you could have opened that door whenever he
was like no survivors he's so fucking cool guys leon did
what grace could never i swear to god i feel like he made it
so i had to open every wall before he fucking melted It's
like all the loot's gone now.
Oh, except for this one.
Never mind.
Oh, I could have went up.
That's where the shotgun shell is where.
Oh my god.
I'm full of ammo again.
I feel like I'm just going to save the shotgun for bosses.
Alright, give me a sec.
Gotta sharpen my knife.
Give me a sec.
Sharpen it.
Just sharpen my knife.
Just got a monster on it real quick.
Oh, here it is, guys.
Guys, a lot of developers worth hours went overtime for this
one animation.
We got 07 to the hard-working developers for giving...
this gift to us oh that pov shot we had to see the arm the
arm bulging off of his shirt barely containing up okay all
right minus uh right 60 left 40 right 80
reduces muzzle fries the barrel looks like brown fucking
neat oh maybe i do look it just for fun let's put that on oh
just for fun
reload the sink i need you guys to know the doves worked
weeks to perfect that particular animation i am surprised
that shirt can even contain And all that muscle.
Look at that.
More shotgun shells.
Wow.
I surely...
I told you guys.
It's raining ammo.
He doesn't even need the injector.
Massive pecs contained by magic.
all right what is my goal here oh there's another club we
know where to go guys well look at all these closets okay
victor's office how do i get there what the wait how do i
get there this
is not helpful where the leads there
oh yeah these are all the notes that i got from before wait
if i all the zombies chat if i clear all the zombies as leon
they don't show back up right
sarah's on top left oh here it is wait central huh right
yeah or do i go left side oh i guess a bar and lounge yeah
dokey the game just came out
it's fine i'll just kill the sire Oh, look at that.
More shotgun shells.
Look at that.
I'm just gonna kill the side right off the bat.
Fuck it.
Who cares if she starts singing?
Wait, actually?
That's right.
You think I care?
You know what?
Boom!
Oh, shit.
It's fire.
That's right.
Oh, melee attack.
Oh, yeah.
I did it for Leon.
What's this?
Oh, I can't even do anything about it.
But...
Oh, he's gonna turn.
Oh, wait, that was a blister head.
Oh, fuck, wait.
Head.
No head.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Let me try and see.
I can't just blow it up for her.
Nope.
I had to test the theory.
I had to test it.
I had to make sure, guys.
I had to make sure.
Leon is just gonna find 40 more bullets later.
It's not a waste for Leon, guys.
Just remember, you can just find 40 more bullets.
He'll just...
Yeah, isn't that gun was for Grace?
Not for me.
What the fuck?
I hope that's not...
Oh.
That's fine.
That was not fine.
It's okay.
Alright.
Try to save that for Grace.
Nah.
She doesn't need it.
Leon is more important, guys.
all right it's time grace that's future grace's problem
that's future dokey and grief's this problem all right nice
okay all the heads are gone what a fucking shame that's good
no except for this guy but that's fine all right wait unless
oh oh oh my god oh oh my god oh how
did he save you it's okay it's okay truly truly okay nice
all right i knew it i knew you weren't real i knew you
weren't real i'm gonna sharpen my knife before it i fucking
knew it i was like your head your your head
wow thing after another that's crazy that out of everybody
oh my resident evil senses were tingling
that's why is there intense music in that room
Oh, yeah.
Oh Oh,
actually, but yeah, I don't waste it My shoot
Run run run oh
my god.
Oh my god.
This is not a very ideal situation for me Okay, it's fine.
All right kick Axe oh god
there you go kick that's right boom oh reload reload reload
but watch this boom oh that's right and then combo
look at that got all my shotgun shells that i used look at
look at the health I have full HP.
Never punished.
Except for the 80 bullets.
80 pistol bullets.
But I got all my shotgun bullets back.
So technically, never punished.
Look at that.
Oh, and look at that.
You are not real.
I fucking knew it.
Oh, wait.
He's just not real.
Oh, my God.
Go!
Who gave him an axe?
Who the fuck gave him an axe?
Okay, it's fine, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Let me see if he's cut his head off.
Alright, we gotta...
Alright.
Normal guy with an axe.
Who will win?
Alright, oh nice.
I knew it.
They always keep things in the jars.
Oh?
Wait, how can I parry?
Oh, you mean if they...
I can parry them in my app?
Okay, that's...
Oh, look at that.
Look at...
Oh, my God.
It's like...
I got back all the ammo I lost in that one fight.
Look at that.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I actually got back everything.
You're not real.
I refuse...
Why are...
Okay, maybe he's just decoration.
I don't trust you.
Okay.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
That's right.
Give me your knee.
Okay, now you're dead, dead.
I never trust that.
If I see...
If I see you have your head...
there's no way oh shit okay wait watch this okay wait watch
this oh my god you're so cool
why can't i just play leon the next three hours like it's so
cool It's not fair.
How can I go back?
Guys, I don't think I can go back.
I don't know if I'm strong enough.
Guys, I don't know if I'm strong enough to go back to
Greece.
Oh, that's not good.
No, you.
Every single time.
Did I just throw this?
What the fuck, Ruby?
There we go.
How is there more heads?
Did I kill all of them?
Oh.
Oh, I think that was the one guy I forgot about.
I missed the one guy
All right That one grenade was just aura Thank you Leon
It was to send a message
He's so much aura there's a one guy that i didn't see pretty
sure i found victor's private office nice work lock it up
yes ma'am he's him chat he's him but as you think of the
super chat think you think chris used a muscle virus leon
did that actually 100 natural please let me nap on that just
yeah stand in line fuzzy there's a there's a 40-year wait
limit wait time should have signed the wait list sherry
you're killing me
i found some information about our illness our symptoms
confirm a t-virus oh shit it's sherry oh yeah
oh no don't worry leon you might be immune Well, hey, at
least we're in together, right?
It's okay.
Lear, they couldn't kill you off.
There's no way.
Where we got him?
There's no...
You know, Lear is like, in Japan.
He's like, I think he's like, what, rank?
It was either Lear and Dante were, like, top five, right?
Of, like, the most popular video game man in Japan.
Grace, where's she got to do this?
There's no way.
They could never do that to Lear.
He's literally their money maker.
There's no way men and women wish they could be Leon or with
Leon either works.
No,
you can't do this to me.
You can't do this to me.
anyway
it's not guys guys don't leave we still have to give away we
still we still have to give away three hours and 10 three
three hours and 50 minutes of grace rewarded me with 10
minutes of leon i mean That's five minutes more.
They did give me five minutes more playtime with Leon.
You know, like, I...
Figures can't be choosers, guys.
I mean, I...
Guys, I don't know if I can go back, guys.
He was so cool.
But they were cool.
I don't...
Where is my equality?
right so where's it oh they they know they're like you want
your leon time you gotta get
they know we'll keep playing for leon they they know let him
rest he is it he can rest when he dies which is not in this
game which would be like never because he he'll live forever
he's gonna get the gorty virus which will mutate him and
then he'll but the mutation is that he'll stay the same but
then he'll live forever so that so that we can all enjoy
leon so our future generations can keep on enjoying leon for
years and years and years until the sun explodes like
the the eternal Leon forever they oh it's so it's so evil
it's so evil they give you a taste of what I like how like
you there's no such thing as wasting bullets for Leon it's
it's literally I log in as Leon and then I shoot my gun 20
times and the game was like good for you Doki here's 50
bullets and then Grace she survives 20 zombies chasing after
her she opens a drawer and they're like here's one bullet
Grace here's one bullet for surviving 50 zombies while you
were taking care of a blind girl a blind little girl who
can't even fucking walk because for some reason legs are too
good for her i guess one and you were very very if you're a
very very good girl grace maybe maybe you get two bullets
but oh no you want more ammo you want you want that one shot
You gotta work for it, girl.
You gotta...
You gotta earn your ammo.
And then they look at Leon and be like, Oh, no.
Oh, no, Leon.
I can't believe you had to use that one shotgun bullet.
Here's 50 more.
Oh, Leon, you worked so hard.
You know what?
Here's 10 grenades, too.
Here's...
And then, back to Gracie.
one more ammo you ungrateful bitch go kill more zombies and
craft your own ammo go go go craft your own ammo you're so
ungrateful go you didn't work hard enough for this ammo
Leon worked so hard for it though he don't understand it's
generational he survived
to have this privilege grace has to work she has to earn her
keep guys she yeah leon's a professional grace grace is just
an amateur
many thank you for the super chat thank you thank you why
can't you be more like leon grace you really yeah go collect
blood and make your own animal you're so ungrateful you're i
can't believe you're so greedy even asking for one herb leon
would never ask for an herb they say as they gave leon 20
herbs scattered across one room again frozen thank you the
super chat thank you thank you sorry grace but i could do is
one herb and a bottom um king thank you for the super chat
thank you they sponsored street by capcom better and it
works though it works they give me small doses of leon so i
can so i can suck it up every they reward me with little
leon doses to get me through the grace storyline every time
i'm on grace i'm like it's okay doki just 10 more minutes
just just keep do it for leon Gabe, remember how great you
felt when you just killed everything?
Oh, just, you can do this, Doki.
Just, just, just work, just work a little harder.
We have to backtrack uphill both ways, Grace.
I'm just thanking for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, Grace, you didn't have to go through Resident Evil 2.
You didn't have to go through Resident Evil 4.
You've never had to go through the hell that Leon went
through.
He worked for it.
It's like we're hazing her right now.
We're hazing Grace.
Like N6 too.
Yeah, yeah.
I went through everything.
He deserves a vacation.
We're literally, we're like hazing the newbie right now.
it's yeah anyway that was fun though um well until i found
out we're until until the last two minutes but that that was
that i don't know how we had a almost six hour stream guys
but um leon was so fun
was i can't but leon was that that 15 minutes of leon felt
felt like six hours that gave me my six hour dopamine boost
anyway guys let's do it for those who don't know they're
they're a huge thank you to MSI for sponsoring this stream.
honestly, if they didn't sponsor, I would not play the game
because of course I heard about how scary.
I mean, I played the demo.
It was very scary.
And well, I watched someone play the demo.
And so I never didn't really want to play Resident Evil
because of that.
And thank you to MSI for sponsoring my adventures with grace
today and ashley too i i really appreciate escorting a blind
girl today i thank you thank you msi the struggles of grace
i can't believe they were able to improve the ashley
mechanic i i never thought the day that the Ashley mechanic
could be improved on it's like oh my god you know what would
be better than escorting someone that can walk on her own
and um can hide in the closet and also can see, what if you
had to escort someone that had none of those that had none
of those characteristics and instead of escorting them you
had to carry them and then when you're carrying them you
can't do anything else I'm worried I'm worried that that's
not the end of Ashley too because she's still alive she
didn't she didn't let go of the courts guys I don't
understand why she didn't let go I would have came back for
her she lied i i would have came back for her guys i if she
let go if she had if she only let go of that of that quirks
i could have came back i i i would have came back for her
with backup with
anyway okay all right i'm solid all right so let me uh pull
up the giveaway stuff real quick now all right all right
giveaway i think i would definitely i would have 100 like i
would have had the my i that braille puzzle oh my god i i do
not think i do not think she got in the FBI by pure skill
and intellect I that made me that made me a little worried
that that was our FBI agent I that made me really worried I
really tried so hard to contain my anger because I could not
wrap my head around the fact that she would not brute force
a three symbol critical thinking it just it's like american
idol they're like she has a sob story we have to let her in
her mom's dead we should let her in and same with same with
she must have wrote a fucking killer college application
because she wrote about how her mom died to an evil cult and
then the college was like we gotta accept her her mom died
from the evil cult and she had to watch all that And like, I
swear she must have had a really good college essay to get
into Harvard, to get into the FBI.
Because there is no way, there is no way that her first
thought when she saw Braille was to get the blind kid and
then escort her through 50 zombies and think that that was
the best option.
from someone that took multiple tests to get into the FBI.
It's very hard.
I know I should suspend my disbelief because Yoki, this is a
video game about zombies.
Obviously, it's not real.
And then I'm thinking, can suspend my belief in a lot of
things but but if she thinks getting a blind child to solve
a puzzle that was made for literal second graders then she's
an analyst not a don't say that that makes it worse if she
is an FBI analyst and in her analyzation of the situation
made her think you would no you would know I would brute
force that the first thing I would think of is that I would
brute force that shit I mean like I'm not coming back for a
blind kid
minute distance between the prison cell and 20 zombies
if i even more so if i'm panicking like the she's analyzing
like what the she's analyzing at this point yeah okay sorry
I had to let that out you don't understand I I was ready to
yell but I was holding back because I knew I knew if I knew
I could would have it would go through my soundproofing it
would 100% pierce my soundproofing because that was that
that that fucking killed me I
That looking I let a lot of things go But her first thought
was to bring a blind child Was where I draw the line Anyway
Anyway To win Alright it's gonna be 10 winners Um 10 winners
um to enter the giveaway for your chance i hope you all
progress further than me before i play the next part for
those who win it it's okay all you have to do is exclamation
point enter for a chat enter that's all you have to do um
and exclamation point enter um again thank you for msi for
sponsoring the stream um they're gonna have a current
promotion for resident evil the new resident evil requiem
game um so by by buying selected msi monitor and posting a
review on a designated platform you can claim your very own
copy of resident evil requiem or if you already purchased an
msi product before and purchased an msi selected monitor you
can get an extra hundred dollar hundred dollars for your
steam wallet to buy whatever game you um i use their i use
your monitors i'm currently using their msi mpg 271 qr qd
old x50 monitor um it's really good especially if you like
competitive gaming yeah i get 500 hertz when i play like fps
games and it's very you know it helps a lot um it really
does help out a lot um if you're more competitive you want
to climb in ranks because it makes a huge difference uh a
huge difference gameplay.
But yeah, QDLOD is the best choice for Resident Evil 9.
All right, for this giveaway, I'd like to mention that, um,
I don't know, let me check if I'm going to check real quick.
All right, so the mod that handles the Doki merch account,
um, they are unfortunately, uh, still sleeping right now.
So when they wake up, they're going to contact all the
people that won the giveaway.
If one of the mods could write down all the names, and pass
it down to the mod that handles the dokey merch twitter
account um to uh um so that you know they could just look
them up and everything so yeah um if you have won um if you
win the giveaway feel free to dm dokey merch uh dokey merch
and show proof that that is your uh okay i'll show the dokey
okay let me all right i think it'd be easier if like you the
winners just dm the dokey or twitter account but make sure
your dms are open okay guys uh your twitter dms um if you
get picked on dm at dokey merch on twitter to claim um but
if they oh my gosh uh and show proof and show proof that
you're that's your youtube account by the way uh because you
know obviously your twitter account might not match might
not match up with uh uh would not be the same username as
your youtube account so make sure that you know to just show
proof that that is your youtube account that have that you
won to to claim the rise of evil requiem game code um most
likely oh not most likely sorry um we have 10 codes to give
away and um or you don't have DMs open, you don't claim your
code, or you don't have DMs open, the next dragon will claim
your prize.
Anyway, another dragon will claim your prize whenever the
mod wakes up.
All right, we're going to start now.
All right, we might blast through this because there's 10 of
them.
First winner, Krats, congratulations, Krats.
Congratulations, Krats 240 for winning the first code.
um but yeah feel free to keep feel free to uh keep pressing
exclamation point enter if you haven't entered yet um
spamming it doesn't mean you get more entries guys just so
just so you know spamming it doesn't mean you get more
entries guys just so you know i i just but if you haven't
entered yet um if you haven't entered yet make sure to enter
we said nine more in game codes to Pineapple bun,
congratulations for the second game code.
I'm gonna, don't worry, I'm just gonna make sure.
Pineapple bun, congratulations.
Make sure you DM at dohi merch and make sure on Twitter and
to claim your game code and also showing proof that that is
your YouTube account.
All right, eight more to go, guys.
Over 9074, congratulations.
over nine zero seven four congratulations for the third okay
guys i also might start losing track of how many we've uh
how many we've like pulled also there is a possibility that
i might start losing count because i this is my first stream
ever since i got back from being sick and i am still sick i
might be delirious right now
Barry 8389.
Congratulations on being, I believe, number four.
I believe number four of receiving the Resident Evil game
code.
Yay!
Congratulations!
Okay, four.
Okay, five more.
We're almost halfway through.
And I'm speeding through this because a lot of people
already entered.
So I think I could just keep pulling.
Dex Taga.
Congratulations on number five.
all right text tag congratulations uh huge shout out again
to msi for um for the sponsor and providing all these free
game codes for all you dragoons guys congratulations um all
right now we're halfway through all right winner winner
number six zach jacob
being dragon number six on winning your free your free
resident evil requiem yippee remember like i said remember
to show proof um that uh you uh that it's linked to like
that that is your youtube account um all right let's see all
right pulling up another one
seventh garv mon 7754 congratulations garv mon
congratulations for being a winner number seventh yay all
right two more guys two more everybody whoa who's it gonna
be who is it gonna be missing no congratulations oh wait
three more wait where am i i i i lost track i okay is this
number eight is this i i i don't know i've lost this now
okay now sorry i i saw these numbers blurring together all
these i haven't had all these numbers are starting to blur
together there's too many numbers i can't count a 10
apparently either just look how grace count of three okay
all right number we're pulling for number nine number nine
death phoenix congratulations congratulations on being lucky
number nine for your free resident evil requiem game code i
like all right guys drum roll for the last winner the final
code the final countdown all right here we go make sure guys
if you got picked make sure your dms are open and that you
dm the dokey merch twitter account to claim your code to
make it easier for everyone because like they don't know
like what your twitter account i in the past i'd be like
give us your twitter account and i'm like you know what like
why don't you just dm them like why you just DM the mod
instead of the mod trying to figure out like what Twitter
account is everybody and we realize that that makes it a lot
easier versus the other way around the last time like I was
like why why did we try and figure up like why did we try
and chase ourselves why don't you guys just come to us like
we learn we learn from our mistakes anyway
search me up for my free game code um but why make it easier
for the mods let them let's play a game mods all right um
all right last winner guys robotic accolade congratulations
i like the chase congratulations to everyone to all the 10
dragons that won today's giveaway um we do have a lot of
these giveaways, uh from MSI whenever MSI has been super
supportive um they always send me a lot of game codes
whenever I wait did you sponsor me for last time we had
Monster Hunter we also had soccer um um that's the send us
like free game codes so a huge congratulations uh huge
congratulations to everybody um who got the free game code
and I hope you guys enjoy your Resident Evil Requiem and uh
I hope you guys make it further than I mean obviously you
guys make it further than because like I play like you know
I do series like once a week i need time to reset i need to
build time to reset myself uh to reset myself for for the
grace arc so most likely you guys might beat the game before
i even get to before we get to part two um um anyway guys
i'm uh no i yeah i need time to forget the controls that's
true too i got the grace pier i gotta mentally prepare
myself for for the the basement level like the fucking
basement level
okay anyway guys thank you all for coming to the stream um i
missed you guys i you know been sick for five days was
pretty rough so it was nice to get back into streaming again
um and i hope you guys enjoyed today's stream and had a fun
time watching um it was it was truly it was such an it was
an adventure it was it was hey maybe maybe if you play
really really well dokey they might give you five more
minutes of leon
don't just think about it maybe maybe they'll give you five
at five more minutes to leon time their leon recess um all
right guys uh we have a lot of stuff going on right now we
have the senpai squad uh collaborate merch collaboration so
make sure to check that out um i don't know when wait let me
see i did message them asking um uh uh let me double check
uh oh yeah pre-orders will end late march uh so there is
plenty there is uh around a month plus time uh for the
senpai squad collection so um that is a collab we've done
with a comp of a merch company um that uh that does a lot of
stuff for car enthusiasts so there's like air fresheners um
uh floor mat car floor mats uh what else sunshade uh license
plate frame and all of that so yeah there's a lot of really
cool merch there um This will be, I, okay, I did not realize
we had so many merch drops in February because I lost track
of the schedule.
You know, I've been going through a lot.
Like, but I have asked about if this is the last big merch
drop for, for like, you guys have, therefore, like, so you
guys might have a breather.
You guys are going to have a breather period because I was
like, I asked my manager, because I felt really bad.
Like, there's a lot of big merch drops back to back, and I
didn't realize, like, I was like, I'm fucking...
I didn't realize that.
It's unfortunate timing.
So I'm really sorry, guys.
But thank you so much for the support for those.
Thank you so much for the support for those who have
purchased the merch that are out right now.
And I have asked, because my plan was, if we do have another
pink merch drop, I was going to ask them to push that.
Because, like, I know.
I want to give you guys, like, I feel really bad.
I was like, I felt really bad because I was like, oh, no, we
got to...
God, they got rest, they got, they got, they got to rest, I,
I can't do that, you know, I just want to look up for you
guys, um, uh, but luckily, my manager just replied to me and
saying, so, and told me that, that was the last big one for
a while now, so, um, so we can all relax, we can, we can
all, we all relax, guys, just enjoy the time together.
Suddenly, new dog shoots.
I just went, I wanted us to just have fun, not worry about
money stuff.
And just enjoy our time together.
Like right now.
Just enjoying the fun stream the day that we had.
But yeah.
It's nice to be back again.
And member guns.
I will have a bonus stream after the chibi-doki collab
tomorrow So but I don't know what time is what it will be So
a waiting room will just come up after the chibi-doki stream
Because I don't want to just put a waiting because I don't
know how I apparently no nightmares 3 is very short It's a
very short game So we might finish it like super quickly
went on we could we could win off that game But for member
goons uh, I will have it's just gonna be chill relaxing time
We're just gonna talk and chill and all that stuff Um, oh if
it says if the senpai squad merch they sold out for you
where you're living where your country is not within the
shipable uh is not in the list of countries that you can
ship to but um if you message them on twitter um on their if
you message them on twitter or the dokey merch twitter
account they will look into it because uh several dragoons
left a comment saying that oh why does this stay sold out um
and they they instantly fixed it right after like senpai
squad like reached out to several dragoons who were like
wondering why it said sold out and um they added their
country into the shipping list so yeah just feel free to ask
about it and then they'll add your country into the shipping
list also if you guys didn't know every purchase comes with
a free digital wallpaper um if you have not received your
digital wallpaper please feel free to dm uh to send an email
or support ticket um about it but the digital because like
the other illustration that was on the car where I was like
the bounty dokey uh the bounty hunter dokey that will be a
free digital wallpaper for you guys to use uh for every
purchase you don't have to buy the bundle it's just any
purchase that you they asked me if I wanted to make it but
at first they wanted to just make it bundle exclusive but I
was like no put it for every purchase I feel like every
drive you know I don't it's 400 like the bundle is 400 and I
felt like um I felt like you guys like it doesn't matter I
felt like you know we already have the And I was like, just
put it for every purchase.
Like, I don't care.
Like, I feel like it shouldn't be restricted to just a
bundle.
I felt like any purchase is fine for it.
So if you purchase anything and you haven't received the
digital wallpaper or, sorry, 400 Canadian.
Let me wait.
Is it?
Yeah, it's 400 Canadians.
Sorry, my paper money.
I keep forgetting about the exchange rate.
between Canadian dollars and US dollars.
So yeah, so if you bought like just an air freshener, you
know, you can still claim, you can still claim your digital
wallpaper.
Cause you know, I said, I noticed that the other
illustration was not used as merch.
So I asked them if they could just, you know, provide it for
free for you guys.
So ah, I hope you guys like the illustration.
I think the, you know, the, the racing doki queen is really,
cute and and also the bounty hunter doki illustration was
also really really cute um but anyway all right i want to
relax now i used a lot of my today i talked a lot um
literally just got back from being five days sick but i
really miss streaming i really miss talking to you guys uh i
missed yapping a lot with you guys and just you know around
and um glad to be back even though even though i I went
through hell.
I went through hell in that bed.
In that bed.
I was not okay.
I was like, oh, I can't.
Surely I won't get sick again.
I just recovered in January.
I just recovered.
I stopped coughing.
Surely.
Surely I'll be okay in February.
Do it for Leon.
Just remember.
Do it for her.
Do it for him.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up,
and move around.
To get that...
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's so long.
To get that blood flowing.
I was going to say, what comes after that?
It's been so long.
It's just for me.
Head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
My routine was broken, guys.
It was five days.
It must have been 20.
It felt like 20 years.
And head to bed, because you deserve it.
What comes after that?
Oh, head to bed because you deserve it.
Anyway, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
I'm out of my flow.
I'm not in my flow state.
I'll see you guys later, everyone.
See you tomorrow.
Bye, guys.
Bye.